Twitch, Maze, und Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellent.
Direkt 36 Sekunden Stream on, erster Sub.
Das ist nicht zu sagen.
Nice, nice, nice.
Extrem nice.
So, werde heute Arch neu installieren.
Good luck.
Das ist schon mal die beste Distro am Start.
Arch, by the way.
Ich finde es auch wichtig zu erwähnen, dass man heute nicht sein Linux oder sein PC neu installiert,
sondern dass man Arch neu installiert.
Genauso hätte ich es auch geschrieben, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Package Updates.
Moment, warum ist Windows ME hier überhaupt noch an?
Es braucht RAM, äh, nicht RAM, äh, Disk, Disk, SSD Storage, damit es den RAM-Inhalt speichern kann.
Ein RF-Programmer.
Hat der Server-Typ geantwortet? Ja.
Der hat sich sogar richtig gefreut.
Guckt mal hier, ich zeige euch das.
Äh, Twitch, äh, nicht Twitch, äh, Twitter.
Ich weiß X.
Aber niemand, wirklich niemand, nennt irgendjemand von euch das ganze X.
Ich nicht.
X ist so ein dummer Name, Alter.
Ich nenne das immer Twitter.
Ich werde das wahrscheinlich für, wenn es nicht irgendwie umbenannt wird in noch irgendwas Sinnvolles,
dann werde ich es weiterhin Twitter nennen.
So, und das hier hat er geantwortet.
Guckt mal.
Ich habe hier schon wieder vergessen, wie abgrundlich scheiße Twitter mittlerweile ist.
Wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Twitter lädt ja keine Antworten mehr automatisch, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist.
Warum? Nur Elon weiß es.
Er hat geschrieben, also ich denke, wir können dann demnächst das tatsächlich dann, äh, weiter, weitermachen, gucken.
So.
Also, was ich ihm geschrieben habe, ist folgendes.
Man muss diese Nachrichten ernsthaft einzeln laden.
Das ist so für einen Arsch.
Also, was ich geschrieben habe, ist folgendes.
Ich habe gestern geschrieben hier, add ZK-Servers.
Ja, wir konnten das gestern nicht machen, weil wir ein bisschen Probleme hatten.
Hier gibt es ein Summary dazu, was ich ihm geschrieben habe, was das Probleme sind.
Also, es war quasi, dass die Server jetzt Internet-Access haben und dass damit quasi ganz viele Szenarios deutlich mehr, also einfacher werden,
wenn man alles installieren kann, was man will.
Und wenn man sogar Sachen auf den Server und runter vom Server SCPen kann.
Und da ist halt die Frage, kann man das nicht irgendwie ausschalten mit einem Pro-Account?
Weil das Witzige ist, ich finde, die Szenarios sind dadurch schlechter mit einem Pro-Account als ohne Pro-Account, was ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig ist.
Also sprich, man sollte es ausschalten können.
Dann habe ich geschrieben, dass man Port 8080 der SSH-Konsole kriegt, ohne jegliche Authentifizierung.
Also sprich, wenn irgendeiner von euch das Ganze gesehen hat, konnte er sich einloggen.
Und dann habe ich mal noch ein paar andere Sachen beschrieben.
Dass die Public-IP in der Server-Pages-Szenario drin steht und man das automatisch sieht.
Und dass, wenn man sich per SSH einloggt, man Last-Logged-In von der IP, also von meiner Public-IP sieht.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht so schlau.
So, und deswegen würde ich suggesten, dass man in der SSH-Config Print Last-Log setzt.
Wenn man das gesetzt hat, dann passiert hier das da nicht mehr.
Und dass man alles blockt, was irgendwie da halt...
Nicht von einem selbst kommt.
Sondern er hat geantwortet, dass er Punkt 1 und 2 auf jeden Fall macht.
Also im Prinzip, wenn Punkt 1 und 2 gemacht ist, braucht es Punkt 3 und 4 gar nicht mehr.
Weil dann kann sich eh keiner mehr einloggen.
Und er hat es nicht so...
Die anderen Punkte hat er nicht so hundertprozentig verstanden.
Das schreibe ich ihm nochmal ausführlicher.
Aber er meint halt auch, das will er nicht löschen von der Seite.
Weil es eben wichtiger ist, dass...
User ordentlichen Zugriff auf die Server haben.
Als und das ordentlich sehen, anstatt dass man halt Stream-Use-Cases abdeckt.
Das verstehe ich auch.
Das macht auch Sinn.
Aber das ist ja überhaupt kein...
Also 3 und 4 lösen sich ja damit automatisch, wenn 1 und 2 gelöst sind.
Wobei ich tatsächlich das hier ganz gut finden würde, wenn das 4. auch defaultmäßig gesetzt wird.
Aber ich verstehe auch, warum man es nicht machen will.
Weil es ist eben halt nicht Standard auf vielen Distributionen.
Also muss ich mich das nächste Mal halt über irgendeinen VPN...
Über irgendeinen Server hoppen.
Mach ich mir einen Server bei Hetzner und mach von da halt ein SSH drauf oder so.
Ja, das geht ja auch.
Also wenn es Punkt 1 und 2 gibt, wobei ganz ehrlich Punkt 2 reicht schon.
Wenn Punkt 2 umgesetzt ist, dass nicht mehr die gesamte Welt auf Port 80 auf meinen Server drauf kommt.
Ich meine aktuell ist es ja so, wenn irgendjemand mal IPs scannt.
Irgendwelche China-Chinesen-Dudes.
Wenn die mal IPs scannen, kommen sie auf ein Web-SSH, auf eine Server-Instanz einfach drauf.
Einfach...
Einfach mit dem Port, wenn du es aufmachst.
Ich meine, das ist nicht so wild aktuell, weil die Kisten sind ja vor 15 Minuten eh weg.
Aber es ist nicht schön.
Also wenn er das hier machen würde, das würde wahrscheinlich alle Probleme erstmal fixen, die wir haben.
Was ist das hier eigentlich?
Das war es, die anderen Leute hier hochge...
Public Copy-Pasted haben.
Also wenn das gefixt ist, dann...
Können wir das streamen.
Ja.
Und er hat sich gefreut.
Also ich finde das...
Guck mal hier, er hat gesagt hier, thanks so much for your feedback.
Also der findet das nice, dass das jemand ausprobiert hat.
Ich meine, ich habe mir sogar ein Pro-Account gekauft dafür, um das auszuprobieren.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass der Pro-Account wahnsinnig krasse Investitionen gewesen ist.
Der kostet 5, hat mich 5 Dollar gekostet.
Ich muss übrigens noch meine Subscription nachher canceln.
Wobei, ich lasse die Subscription laufen.
Pinted Service.
Pinted Service, nice.
Ich lasse den erstmal ein bisschen laufen.
Vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch einfach eine Jahres-Subscription.
55 Dollar und dann cancele ich es.
Weil, man läuft sonst immer die Gefahr, dass man es vergisst zu canceln.
So, Arch by the way, wir müssen Package-Updates machen.
Warum?
Weil Arch...
Oh ja.
Neo-Fetch.
Übrigens, Neo-Fetch ist gar nicht mehr Neo-Fetch.
Das ist Fake.
Guck.
Neo-Fetch ist nur ein Alias.
Weil Neo-Fetch ist nicht mehr supported.
Fast-Fetch.
Ist the way.
Und wenn uns das sogar schon diese eine Oma auf YouTube zeigt,
dass Neo-Fetch nicht mehr...
Ich habe den Channel vergessen.
Aber ihr wisst vielleicht noch, wie ich meine...
Wenn es da sogar die Linux-Oma auf YouTube zeigt,
dass Neo-Fetch nicht mehr...
Nicht mehr...
The way ist, dann sollte man es auch nicht mehr machen.
Package-Updates.
Keine Package-Updates.
Checken.
Jetbrain-Updates.
Moin.
Open-Source-Subscription.
Das ist in der Tat tatsächlich gar nicht schlecht.
Open-Source-Subscription-Tracker.
Ist das einfach nur eine...
Also ich meine, seriously, wenn das einfach nur eine Webseite ist,
mit...
Wo ich meine Subscriptions eintragen kann,
dann ist das easy,
weil dann kann ich auch einfach eine...
Liste machen bei mir im Notizprogramm.
Im Notizprogramm.
Hä?
Sieht schon mal gut aus.
Empfinde ich optisch...
Ah ja gut, man kann eintragen, wie es bezahlt wird.
Okay.
Muss ich da...
Kann er Seiten...
Kann er auch Seiten crawlen?
Oder muss ich meine 230 Only-Fans-Subscriptions da alle händisch erfassen?
Okay, man muss die alle händisch erfassen.
Aber da...
Das...
Das nervt mich ein bisschen, weil...
Aber ich meine, anders geht's nicht.
Da müsste ich beispielsweise...
Da müsste ich beispielsweise auch meine ganzen Domains eintragen.
Ich werde mir das mal speichern.
Das ist aber eine gute Sache, dass es sowas gibt.
Sehr, sehr nice.
So, ich glaube, wir haben alles updatet.
Es gab ja nichts zum Updaten.
Da müssen wir also auch nicht rebooten.
Warum habe ich ein zweimal Firefox auf?
Ach, von gestern noch.
Ja, kann ich den mal wieder rüberschieben hier.
Du wolltest uns noch ein...
Ach ja, wollte ich...
Echt, wollte ich das?
Ja.
Kann ich aber machen.
Mittlerweile...
Haben sie immer noch nicht geschafft, alles zu überweisen.
Sie haben ja zu viel überwiesen, ne?
Habe ich euch das erzählt?
Die haben zu viel überwiesen und wollten jetzt 80 Euro von mir zurückhaben,
weil sie die Mehrwertsteuer nicht richtig berechnet haben.
Aber das meiste haben sie mittlerweile überwiesen.
Das meiste haben sie überwiesen.
Also, wirklich, ohne Scheiß.
Die sind so ultraunfähig.
Also, wenn wir gerade...
Wenn wir da dabei sind, ja?
Ob...
Also, wenn wir gerade...
Da haben wir öfters das Thema, ob bestimmte Jobs in Zukunft von AIs erledigt werden können.
Ich glaube, das hätten AIs besser und schneller und fehlerfreier erledigt, als die Leuten bei der Versicherung.
Und billiger.
Deutlich billiger für die.
Also, mal die Kosten von der AI abgesehen.
Allein nur meine Anwaltskosten, was die bezahlen müssen, ey.
Wir brauchen den Versicherungs-Champ.
Ich arbeite aber schon...
Ich arbeite schon bei einer Versicherung.
Ich kann nicht bei denen auch noch...
Also, bei denen würde ich nicht arbeiten wollen.
So.
Aber, muss ich das mal überlegen.
Ich hab das...
Ich hab das meiste Geld ist jetzt da, ja?
Es ist wie...
Also, der Witz ist halt...
Der Witz ist halt für die, hätten die das einfach, ganz normal bezahlt...
So, instant.
Dann hätten die sich die ganzen Anwaltskosten gespart.
Eventuell die Gutachterkosten, die Ausfallskosten, die Mahnungs...
Alles.
Die hätten sich alles gespart.
Ich kann es ja verstehen, wenn die Versicherung sagt, ey...
Also, verstehen ja, aber gut finden tue ich es nicht, ja?
Wenn die Versicherung sagt, nee, jetzt nicht mehr.
Die haben ja bezahlt.
Stimmt übrigens gar nicht, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Also, die müssten...
Ich hab so nicht nachgerechnet.
Die müssten mittlerweile alles bezahlt haben, weil ansonsten hätten sie ja nicht...
sagen können, sie haben 80 Euro zu viel überwiesen.
Ich hab es noch nicht nachgerechnet.
Ja?
Also, Mist, was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade sagen?
Manchmal ist Brain lagged, wenn ich...
Wenn ich side getrackt werde.
Ja, genau.
Ich kann es ja noch...
Ich könnte es ja noch nachvollziehen, wenn die Versicherung sagt...
Dass...
Irgend so ein random Dude, der sich bei ihnen meldet und sein Fahrrad bezahlt haben will...
Dass man den ein bisschen hinhält und rumdiskutiert...
Den ich überweist, so nach dem Motto, vielleicht gibt er sich ja damit zufrieden.
Scheint ja bei einigen Versicherungen gängige Praxis zu sein.
Aber, wenn das Erste, was sie hören von mir, über den Anwalt ist...
Oder über einen Anwalt ist...
Dann können die doch nicht davon ausgehen, dass der locker lässt.
Nur weil die sich doof anstellen.
Der freut sich, wenn die sich doof anstellen.
Weil die für jeden Furz, den er lässt, kriegt er extra Gebühren.
Und die bezahlen das.
Also, sie sind eigentlich doppelt bescheuert, wenn sie es dann langsam und nervig machen.
Weil mir ist das egal.
Mich juckt es auch persönlich nicht, ob die drei oder vier oder fünf oder sechs Monate später bezahlen.
Ich habe mir hier schon ein neues Fahrrad gekauft.
Es wird immer nur mehr Geld.
Für mich und für den Anwalt und weniger für die Versicherung.
Was?
Ne.
Also, das wäre ja noch schöner, wenn meine Versicherung irgendwas erhöht, weil mich jemand auf dem Fahrrad umgefahren hat.
Reboot brauchen wir nicht.
Ach, schau mal hier die GitHub-Trends auf.
Die gehen schnell.
Weil wahrscheinlich zu 90% wieder AI, AI, AI, AI ist.
Also.
Das haben wir schon gesehen.
Das fand ich auch sehr spannend.
Da haben wir uns sogar letztens ein Video zu angeguckt.
BENT.
Massively Parallel High Level Programming Language.
Und by the way, selbstverständlich, was sonst?
Placing the Fast.
Mind Blowing Fast Written in Rust.
Haben wir uns das letzte Mal schon ein Video drüber angeguckt.
Da kann man dann solche hässlichen Dinger hier drinnen machen.
Und der guckt, wie man das ordentlich parallelisieren kann, ohne dass man es von Hand sich mit Parallelisierungskonstrukten rumschlagen muss.
So wirklich schön lesbar finde ich das Ganze ja nicht.
Schleifen gibt es nicht.
Es gibt nur so eine Art Rekursion.
Wobei, das ist es irgendwie auch.
Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es nicht mehr genau im Kopf.
Zumindest kann man das Ganze dann automatisch parallelisieren lassen.
Entweder auf der CPU oder sogar mit GPU-Unterstützung.
Richtig coole Sache.
Ist vielleicht mal was, was ich mir in Zukunft just for fun angucke.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich persönlich für irgendwas, was ich programmiere oder in nächster Zeit entwickle, einen Anwendungsfall dafür haben werde.
Aber es gibt sicherlich Anwendungsfälle, die sich konstruieren lassen, wo man das nice dafür benutzen kann.
Ob die dann so sinnvoll ist?
Ja.
Fabric juckt mich nicht.
Java.
Fire Crawl.
Was?
Ah, äh, äh, AI.
China-Chinesen-AI.
Vielleicht.
Ich weiß nicht.
Easy, Easy-Spoder.
Elektro-
Ah, ah, ah.
MonkaS, Alter.
Wenn ich das schon sehe, dann wissen wir Bescheid.
Ich habe Webcrawler.
China-Chinesen-Webcrawler.
Der Captchas umgehen kann oder sowas.
Aha.
Wobei ich noch nicht mal weiß, überhaupt, ob das Chinesisch ist.
Ich...
Achso, ja, das ist ja Firefox.
Die mögen das ja mit Translate, nicht?
So.
Bulletproof React.
Ich bin ja nicht im Frontend-React-Game so aktiv.
Was ich bei React immer nur mitbekommen habe, dass die gefühlt jede zweite Version irgendwas von ihren Basic-APIs ändern und das dann anders aussieht.
Wobei man das bei anderen Frontend-Frameworks ja auch sieht.
Guckt euch Vue an.
Der Umstieg von 2 auf 3.
Sieht auch komplett anders aus.
Sieht nach deutlich mehr React aus.
Oder Svelte sieht jetzt ja auch ein bisschen mehr nach React aus.
Wobei ich sagen muss, ich mag Svelte.
Und die ganzen Sachen, die ich bisher von Svelte 5 gesehen habe.
Ist ja 5, oder?
Die sehen alle tatsächlich, auch wenn es Reactiger aussieht, ganz gut aus.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Äh...
Whatever.
Keine Ahnung.
AI.
Fragt man sich, wann Nintendo an den Start kommt?
Power Toys Trended?
Okay.
Tatsächlich mal eine Sache von Microsoft, die das auch verdient hat.
Es gibt bei Power Toys eh so ein paar Dinger, wo ich mich frage, warum das nicht in Windows eingebaut ist.
Zum Beispiel das Remappen von Keys.
Warum brauchst du dafür extra was?
Warum ist das nicht in Windows eingebaut?
Majora's Mask recompiled?
Das finde ich ja interessant, dass die Majora's Mask recompiled haben vor PC.
Bevor sie Ocarina of Time recompiled.
Ich hätte eigentlich vermutet, dass das einfacher ist, als das.
NeoWim, Stealth, AI.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich würde vermuten, AI für China-Chinesen-Kram.
Das ist cool.
Das haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Das ist wirklich eine nice Anwendung für AI.
Du kannst einen Screenshot droppen.
Und der baut dir dann aus dem Screenshot die Webseite nach mit HTML, CSS.
Also der...
Das ist quasi ein Screenshot-to-Source-Code-Tool.
Das finde ich cool.
Es ist jetzt nicht sowas, was man wahrscheinlich am Ende eins zu eins so verwenden will.
Aber die Idee ist cool.
Ja.
Und es sieht dann so aus.
Screenshot und dann
generatet dir das den Source-Code für eine Seite, die so ähnlich aussieht.
Richtig coole Sache.
Eher so ein Faktor für...
Zur Inspiration.
Jetzt nicht unbedingt für eine fertige App, aber zur Inspiration.
Das ist eh so ein Ding,
was ich mir denke,
dass das ein ganz großes Anwendungsgebiet von AI in Zukunft wird,
sich Inspiration zu holen.
Weil das AI ist wirklich was Kreatives machen, wo du heute...
Also was mit...
Was Kreatives mit...
Wie soll ich das sagen?
Man könnte durchaus sagen, dass die AI-Images schon irgendwie was Kreatives...
Aber mit...
Was Kreatives mit tieferer...
Tiefere...
Ja...
Wie heißt...
Wie soll man das nennen?
Mit tieferer Aussagekraft dahinter.
Ja?
So wie das eben bei künstlerischen Sachen ist.
Ich glaube, da sind wir AI-technisch noch eine ganze Ecke davon entfernt.
Ich glaube, eines der wichtigsten Punkte von AI in Zukunft wird auch werden,
dass man sich da Inspiration holen kann.
Denkanstöße, wo man dann selbst vielleicht auf was kommt, wo man noch nicht dran gedacht hat.
Also quasi so eine Verbindung aus AI-Brain und Mensch-Brain.
Ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert.
Ich kann also nichts zu der Qualität sagen, was da rauskommt.
Ich würde darauf tippen, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt für die maintainbarsten Webseiten sorgt,
sich die damit zu generieren.
Das ist, glaube ich, eher was zur Inspiration.
So nach dem Motto, okay, wie könnte man das machen?
Aha, da habe ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht, das und das zu verwenden.
Nee, du kannst eine Webseite nicht einfach klonen.
Du kannst höchstens ein bisschen die Optik des Frontends nachbauen.
Aber das bringt dir bei weitem nicht die Funktionalität der Webseite.
So, JavaScript, WeChat, aha.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Irgendwas Italienisches?
Ist das Italienisch, Leute?
Oder Spanisch?
Portugiesisch?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Fundamentos, das klingt eher ein bisschen Spanisch, oder?
Okay, irgendwelche.
Ah, ja, ja, Spanisch.
Also, wenn ich da Brasilianisch ist, dann muss das Spanisch sein.
Warte mal, ist Brasilianisch Portugiesisch?
Nee.
Oder?
War das nicht so, dass irgendwie alle Spanisch reden außer Argentinien, die reden Portugiesisch?
Oder war das alle reden Spanisch außer Brasilien und die reden Portugiesisch?
Frache Brasilien.
Okay Chat, ihr habt recht.
Ich habe Unrecht.
Oder, wie es mein Opa sagen würde, ihr habt Recht und ich habe meine Ruhe.
Gibt es nicht eine neue JavaScript Package Registry?
Stimmt, da wollte ich mir auch ein Video zu angucken.
Wie hieß das?
JRS Registry oder so?
Nee, JSR.
Irgendwie so.
Da müssen wir mal gucken, ob wir da ein gescheites Video zu finden.
Weil ich glaube, Fireship hat noch kein Video gemacht.
Den Talk habe ich angefangen, die ersten 5 Minuten zu gucken.
Den fand ich äußerst anstrengend zu gucken.
Aber ich finde die ganzen Sachen von ihm äußerst anstrengend zu gucken.
Der ist 5-Head, aber angenehme Präsentationen macht er nicht.
AI, AI.
Your AI second brain.
Aber wenn ich sowas schon lese, dann glaube ich da immer nicht dran.
Okay, und welches VPN-Zeug.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind bei VPN.
YouTube hat mir vorhin dieses Video hier empfohlen.
Und ich glaube ja, dass da...
Ich glaube, das ist richtig krasses Boomer-TV.
Sagt was zum Thema AI.
Ich habe mir das noch nicht angeguckt.
Aber ich habe letztens eine Statistik gesehen.
Alter der verschiedenen TV-Programm-Zuschauer.
Und ich glaube, 80% der öffentlich-rechtlichen Zuschauer sind über 50.
Also ist die Chance hoch, dass es ein heftigster Boomer-Beitrag über AI ist.
Und nachdem der bloß 3 Minuten 39 lang ist, gucken wir uns den jetzt mal schnell an.
Okay, lass uns mal prädikten.
Es ist auf jeden Fall, es ist auf über 60 sogar.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so typisch öffentlich-rechtlich News-Beitrag mäßig.
So überraschend.
Aber korrekt, seriös gesprochen.
Das ist schon mal klar.
Die sind die Beiträge da immer.
Sie werden garantiert Experten interviewen zum Thema.
Das machen die nämlich ultra gerne.
Da wird dann irgendwelche Leute hingesetzt.
Hier ist Programmierer in Dings, Experte für AI.
Und jetzt sagen sie uns mal dazu was.
Und lass mal noch was prädikten.
Ah ja.
Und sie werden prädikten, dass das alles gar nicht so wild ist oder so.
Wird es die Arbeitswelt ver...
Ne, ne, Fazit.
Fazit.
Wird wahrscheinlich sein.
Auch Boomer-Jobs sind komplett sicher.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Die Stimme kennen viele.
Das ist das Gesicht dazu.
Okay, ich hab schon mal richtig gelegen mit dem Sprechen.
Lisen Ripier aus Frankfurt ist an fast allen deutschen Flughäfen zu hören.
Sie spricht aber auch Imagefilme, E-Learnings, Texte für Unternehmen auf Englisch und Deutsch.
Hörmann Moving Racks bietet eine kosten- und platzeffiziente Goods-to-Person-Picking-Lösung.
Na komm, sowas kann doch easy.
Das muss eine AI heutzutage machen, oder?
Also da brauchst du wahrscheinlich...
Also für sowas, für so 0815-Massenware brauchst du wahrscheinlich echt keine Sprecher mehr.
Auch für sperrige und schwere Güter.
Als selbstständige Profisprecherin hat sie jahrzehntelang...
Außerdem, es hört sich jetzt schon an wie eine AI, Mann.
...sehr gut verdient.
Doch seit über einem Jahr brechen ihr die Einnahmen weg.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Die Unternehmen sparen, Preise werden gedrückt.
Reise werden...
...nicht gedrückt.
Ein Preis ist dann, wenn sich beide Seiten übereinstimmen, was angemessen ist.
Actually.
Wichtig, Thor.
Ihr wisst, ich hab mal für ganz kurze Zeit eine BWL-Ausbildung gemacht.
Das heißt, dass gerade die großen Unternehmen jetzt die Werbebudgets eingestampft haben oder ganz stark reduziert haben.
Ja, was natürlich auch seitdem immer häufiger kommt, dass die so, ach nö, das ist uns zu teuer.
Dann machen wir es mit einer...
Ich würde sagen, es wird Zeit, sich einen Fiverr-Account zu machen.
Sie und ihre Kollegen befürchten, dass KI, also künstliche Intelligenz und synthetische Stimmen, in Zukunft ihre Arbeit übernehmen.
Das musst du nicht befürchten. Bei dem Intro, ja, was war denn das? Spot. Das würde ich nicht befürchten.
Ich würde mich wundern, wenn das heute noch nicht so weit ist.
Also künstliche Intelligenz und synthetische Stimmen in Zukunft ihre Arbeit übernehmen.
Ich würde sagen, seit Ende 2022.
Letztes Jahr hat sich das Auftragsvolumen halbiert.
Und dieses Jahr, es ist unterirdisch.
Also ich hab Wochen, da kommt überhaupt kein Anruf und keine Anfrage.
Das wundert mich nicht.
Das hab ich so noch nie erlebt.
Man muss auch sagen...
Sorry, da schon wieder stoppen muss.
Ich weiß, 3 Minuten 39 Video, ich mach laufend Pause.
Aber man muss aber auch eins sagen, die haben sich da ein Thema rausgepickt, was sich so krass verbessert hat, wie kaum ein anderes die letzten Jahre über.
Also ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwätzen müssen.
Also gerade Text-to-Speech ist so unglaublich.
Extrem viel besser geworden, die letzten Jahre.
Mittlerweile kann man das kaum unterscheiden.
Es ist teilweise besser als das Original mittlerweile.
Mit Text-to-Speech.
Also zum Beispiel, ja.
Wenn ich Englisch rede versus, wenn ich Englisch mit KI-Unterstützung rede von der Aussprache.
Das ist besser.
Und ich gucke, ich gucke mir heutzutage auf YouTube tatsächlich sogar ganz gerne Videos an.
Was weiß ich über irgendwelche Game-Lore, Dungeons & Dragons-Lore, Warhammer-Lore, World of Warcraft-Lore.
Ich kann dabei super pennen bei solchen Videos.
Und diese Videos sind zunehmend AI gesprochen.
Mit irgendwelchen Models, mit bekannten Sprechern drinne.
Und ohne Scheiß, das hört sich fast nicht mehr zu unterscheiden an.
Also von der Originalstimme.
Die Zeiten von Microsoft.
Sam sind vorbei.
Microsoft Sam Text-to-Speech wird heute echt nur noch verwendet für irgendwelches Gemehme.
Ja.
Oder für irgendwelche Anime-Sounds.
Anime-Girl-Sounds.
Wobei, das ist ja ein, nur weil es japanisches Text-to-Speech-Model ist, müssen ja nicht gleich Anime-Sounds sein.
Das ist auch schon outdated.
Das habe ich seit ein paar Jahren.
Das geht mittlerweile deutlich besser.
Eigentlich müsste ich mein, eigentlich müsste ich hier mein, äh, Text-to-Speech und Dings mal neu bauen.
Weil das geht heutzutage garantiert schon viel, viel besser als vor ein paar Jahren, wo ich diese AI, äh, wo ich das, nicht AI, wo ich das Text-to-Speech hier mal eingebunden habe.
Ja.
Okay, weiter.
Das ist auch ein bekanntester Anbieter davon.
Ja. Ja.
Das ist richtig gut geworden.
Also gerade Text-to-Speech hat man eigentlich Copyright auf seine KI-Stimme.
Ehrlich gesagt glaube ich, dass das in Zukunft noch einige Rechtsstreitigkeiten verursachen wird.
Also generell, nicht nur was AI-Stimme angeht, sondern ich glaube, dass AI-Ergebnisse, wenn sie irgendwo verwendet werden, in Zukunft noch für den ein oder anderen Rechtsstreit sorgen werden.
Ja.
Das habe ich gar nicht mitbekommen.
Jaja, da wird es noch deutlich mehr Sachen geben.
Okay.
Professionelle Tonstudios bekommen immer häufiger Anfragen von Kunden, die hoffen, mit KI Geld zu sparen.
Und vieles ist inzwischen möglich. Sprache kann zum Beispiel komplett in eine andere Stimme umgewandelt werden.
Okay, dann starten wir mit dem ersten Tag. Und läuft.
Nach 18 Jahren endlich wieder Fußballfieber in Deutschland.
Auch Frank...
Das kann wirklich eine AI machen.
Frankfurt ist 2024 wieder Gastgeber für Fans aus aller Welt.
Und dann können wir uns das mal anhören, wie Alison mit einer Männerstimme klingen würde.
Nach 18 Jahren endlich wieder Fußballfieber in Deutschland.
Doch die vielfältige menschliche Stimme kann die KI, oder auf Englisch AI, noch nicht einfach mit ein paar Klicks am Computer machen.
Auch bei einfachen Texten braucht sie immer noch...
By the way, ich hatte übrigens recht, ne?
Einmal wieder Beitrag gesprochen ist und dass sie irgendwelche Experten am Start haben, die wieder was dazu sagen.
...echte Menschen als Vorbild.
Im Moment ist halt Machine Learning. Das heißt, die Maschine, der Computer hat etwas gelernt.
Ich, ich, ich predikte mal, so einen Beitrag kannst du in Zukunft komplett KI generieren.
Das Ding ist aber, dass der Beitrag da nicht richtig, richtig sein wird.
Dass du immer noch ein bisschen was korrigieren musst am Ende, weil irgendwas dazu halluziniert wurde.
Moment, was erzählt er?
Die Maschine, der Computer hat etwas gelernt und dafür muss man ihm ganz viele Beispiele geben.
Und es ist nicht so, dass der Computer oder die AI irgendwas aus dem Nichts herzaubert.
Also nichts entsteht aus dem Nichts. Es braucht eine Basis und das ist immer eine menschliche Stimme.
Das war jetzt die Boomer-Beruhigung.
Die Boomer-Beruhigung, die eingebaut wurde in dem Video.
Was er nicht dabei sagt, aber was er garantiert weiß, ist, dass das ja schon passiert ist.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sich der Sprecher da hinstellen muss, um was reinzusprechen, um eine ordentliche KI-Stimme zu generieren.
Also wenn du eine KI-Stimme von exakt ihr generieren willst, ja dann schon.
Aber wenn du einfach nur eine gute KI-Stimme haben willst, da gibt es ja schon fertig trainierte Models.
Ja, die wurden auch mit Sprachsamples und allem trainiert.
Natürlich.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so, als müssten die das jetzt explizit in diesem Tonstudio dafür machen.
Das war jetzt ein bisschen Boomer-Beruhigung, so nach dem Motto, ah, man braucht immer noch menschliche Sprache.
Ja, aber das ist ja schon passiert.
Doch die Technik entwickelt sich rasant weiter.
KI ist auf dem Vormarsch in all unseren Lebens- und Arbeitsbereichen und bietet auch Chancen, sagen Experten vom Fraunhofer-Institut.
Wir werden in den nächsten Jahren, über 50.000 Hausärzte werden uns fehlen.
Wir haben einen riesengroßen Fachkräftemangel in Deutschland, auch im Handwerk, auch in den Pflegeberufen natürlich.
Es ist aber sicherlich nichts, was ich von KI ersetzt haben will.
Ich glaube schon, dass dann die KI eher sehr viele positive Potenziale mit sich bringt.
Ja, also ich warte auch drauf, bis die KI mir das Wasser abpumpt aus dem Keller.
Mal gucken, dass wir nicht dadurch eine Situation schaffen, wo auf der einen Seite viele Fachkräfte fehlen und auf der anderen Seite Leute ihren Job verlieren, die dann nicht mehr vermittelbar sind.
Ja, die Bullshit.
Die Bullshit-Jobs kommen weg. Die Bullshit-Jobs kommen weg. Einige.
Alison Repay und ihre Kollegen jedenfalls machen sich ernsthafte Sorgen um ihre Zukunft und schauen sich auch schon...
Nicht, dass ich sagen will, dass Synchronsprecher wirklich nicht, ja, Synchronsprecher ist kein Bullshit-Job.
...nach Alternativen um.
Ich ertappe mich immer wieder dabei. Ich habe jetzt auch schon ein paar Fortbildungen gemacht, weil ich auch nicht so ein Mensch bin, der rumsitzt.
Ich lerne auch gerne neue Sachen, aber dann komme ich...
Ohne Scheiß würde die Alison Ripper heißen. Da wäre das so der krasseste, weiß nicht, Markenname überhaupt. Alison Ripper.
Auch gerne neue Sachen, aber dann komme ich...
Energydrink, whatever.
...dass ich diesen Beruf so liebe. Produktion, meine Stimme zu leihen, das ist etwas, wofür ich brenne, was mir eine große Freude macht und was ich wahnsinnig schade fände, wenn ich das nicht mehr machen dürfte.
Ja.
Also, ich muss jetzt mal ein bisschen eine Runde Monolog halten.
Zu diesem Thema, und zwar...
Ups.
Ja.
Threadripper.
Genau.
Ja, jetzt habe ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte.
Also, genau.
Ich persönlich denke ja, dass das schon teilweise sowohl überschätzt als auch unterschätzt wird für die nächsten Jahre.
Natürlich kann ich auch nur raten, so wie 100% alle anderen Leute aktuell auch nur raten können.
Aber ich denke, das ist zumindest meine Meinung dazu, ich denke da, wo wirklich Kreativität und menschliche Note gefragt ist, das wird KI auch auf absehbare Zeit nicht übernehmen.
Das meiste ist aber halt so 0815-Massenware.
Oder vieles von dieser 0815-Massenware wird in Zukunft auch von AI übernommen werden können.
In welcher Art und Weise auch immer. Es gibt ja noch mehr außer Text-to-Speech.
Man wird in Zukunft halt immer weniger Bullshit-Jobs haben.
Ja, also zum Beispiel wie Excel-Tabellenreport generieren, einmal am Tag und solche Geschichten.
Das wird sicherlich zurückgehen.
So diese richtig typischen, stupiden Bullshit-Jobs, davon wird es deutlich weniger geben.
Aber der Elektriker, der mir das Ladegerät für das Elektroauto hier installiert hat, den wird so schnell keine KI ersetzen.
Wie soll das Ganze funktionieren?
Ja.
Dass er sich eventuell, dass in diesem Bereich allgemein für Planung von Anlagen oder so,
dass da vermehrt KI oder für wie kann ich möglichst wenig Material, möglichst viel Fläche abdecken mit Kameras oder so,
dass dafür AI benutzt werden wird, das steht für mich außer Frage.
Ja, das wird passieren.
Aber das muss sich am Ende immer noch jemand angucken.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Das sage ich.
Das ist das, was ich meine.
Zur Inspiration.
Und ich glaube, dass KI eines der Hauptanwendungsfälle mit jetzt noch, was man schon kennt, zusätzlich tatsächlich auch sein wird zur Inspiration.
Für Denkanstöße.
Zumindest, also wie gesagt, den Elektriker wird es nicht überflüssig machen.
Jemand so ein, ich werde nach Zeilen bezahlt, unsinnigen Business-Kram auszukacken, Programmierer, den wird es vielleicht auch überflüssig machen.
Ein, ich kann nur auf Meetings rumhocken, Manager.
Und ab und zu mal wichtig klingende Sachen wiederholen.
Und ansonsten keinerlei Mehrwert haben.
Denen wird das auch ersetzen.
Irgendwelche Bullshit-Jobs, die Low-Quality-Texte abtippen den ganzen Tag.
Oder Reports von irgendwelchen Sachen, die sich easy digitalisieren lassen.
Die heute noch per Fax verschickt werden, whatever.
Reports generieren sicherlich auch der Entwickler, der versteht.
Und wir legen mal hier die Betonung auf versteht.
Was gebraucht wird.
Was jemand haben will.
Auch nach einer nicht so tollen Erklärung.
Denen wird das nicht ersetzen.
Ein Lehrer, der nicht nur stur was ablesen kann von seinem vielleicht dann immer noch Overhead-Projektor.
Denen wird das auch nicht ersetzen.
Und ich denke, aktuell wird das KI-Thema, und das ist jetzt ja nichts Neues, in den letzten Jahren schon.
Sieht man ja auch bei Fireship.
Fireship schießt alle.
Hier, das ist schon.
Das nächste.
Alle gefühlt drei Stunden ein neues KI-Video raus.
Aktuell wird das alles extrem gehypt.
Schon auch zu Recht.
Wir haben enorme Fortschritte gemacht.
Gerade, wenn wir hier bei dem Thema Text-to-Speech bleiben.
EF Programmer, danke für den Sub.
Gerade, wenn wir beim Thema Text-to-Speech bleiben.
Aber meiner Meinung nach wird das auch teilweise relativ unrealistisch aufgehypt.
Also, es ist ja nicht gesagt, dass die Entwicklung, wie wir es jetzt gerade erleben.
Beziehungsweise, wie wir das gerade erlebt haben.
Die letzten zwei, drei Jahre über.
Exakt in dem Speed weitergeht für immer.
Manche sagen, okay, das geht nicht nur in dem Speed weiter.
Das geht sogar noch immer schneller.
Und wenn dann AI sich irgendwann selbst verbessern kann.
Sonst was, ich kenne das alles.
Aber ich mache ein Beispiel.
Ich mache ein Beispiel, Leute.
Wo man sieht, dass Erwartung und tatsächliches Eintreten der Erwartung ganz weit auseinander liegen kann.
Hättet ihr mal die Leute gefragt.
1970 bei der Mondlandung.
1969, oder?
Moment, Moment.
Mondlandung, ja.
1969, ja.
Hättet ihr die Leute mal gefragt bei der Mondlandung 1969.
Also, was denkt ihr denn im Jahr 2000?
Was hat sich daraus jetzt alles entwickelt?
Die Leute hätten euch gesagt, ey, wir sind mindestens schon auf dem Mars gewesen.
Wir sind im Sonnensystem verteilt.
Wir haben zig Raumstationen und alles.
Das sieht man ja auch in den Filmen, die damals rausgekommen sind.
Und fliegende Autos und solche Geschichten.
Ganz wilde Dinger.
Und was ist davon passiert?
Relativ wenig.
Und vor allem ganz anderes Zeug, als man sich so gedacht hat.
Heute haben wir Smartphones.
Und wir sind über den Mond nie richtig rausgekommen.
Zumindest bemannt.
Und selbst das haben wir Jahrzehnte nicht mehr gemacht.
Also, da sieht man das.
So, die Erwartung und der Hype nicht unbedingt immer zu dem führt, was man sich so denkt.
Oder fragt mal, mal ein anderes Beispiel.
Mal ein Beispiel hier aus der IT und der Technik.
Fragt mal Intel vor ein paar Jahren, was wir im Jahr 2024 für CPUs haben werden.
Die hätten euch gesagt, Single Core CPUs mit, keine Ahnung, 80 Gigahertz oder sowas.
Hättet ihr Intel gefragt, bevor es absehbar war,
dass diese ganze Dual Core, 8-fach Core, 16-fach, 32-fach Core Geschichte kommt.
Und es gibt Roadmaps von Intel von früher.
Es gibt Roadmaps von Intel.
Da steht drinne, markiert, grün, gelb, rot, Probleme, die wir gelöst haben.
Probleme, wo wir eine Lösung uns, ja, schon ausmalen können.
Und rot Probleme, wo wir noch überhaupt keine Lösung für haben.
Und natürlich umso weiter diese Roadmap in die Zukunft gegangen ist.
Umso mehr wurden die ganzen roten Felder mehr, ja.
Aber die hatten Roadmaps mit Single Core CPUs.
Nur Single Core CPUs.
Also zum größten Teil Single Core CPUs.
Aber halt die übelsten Taktraten.
Mehr Taktraten, als wir jetzt haben.
Die hatten halt den Plan, wir machen so weiter, wie gehabt.
Und das sah ja auch damals so aus.
Aber das ging auch nicht so weiter.
Das ging auch nicht so weiter.
Das heißt, dass nur weil etwas saumäßig schnell geht,
und weil es so aussieht, als würde es immer so weiter gehen,
oder gar noch schneller gehen,
heißt das nicht, dass diese Erwartungen sich immer erfüllen.
Also es hat sich die letzten, die habe ich auch schon gesagt,
es hat sich die letzten Jahre ohne Frage enorm viel getan.
Gerade im Thema Text to Speech ist mega viel passiert.
Sprecher heutzutage kannst du kaum unterscheiden von echten Sprechern,
wenn das gut gemacht ist.
Kommt auch ein bisschen auf das Thema an.
Immer wenn es um realistische, realistische Emotionen geht,
ja, bei einem Sprint, dann ist es natürlich schwierig,
wenn du einfach nur irgendwelche Texte,
mehr oder weniger gut betont, runterlesen kannst,
dann ist AI gut.
Aber sagen wir mal, ein Hörbuch sprechen,
wo es ja auch um das Reinversetzen geht,
wie das gesagt wird, dann brauchst du auf jeden Fall für eine AI,
ich sage nicht, dass man das nicht machen kann,
da brauchst du auf jeden Fall so diesen Regisseur-Part für eine AI
noch menschlich dabei.
Um zu sagen, an dieser Stelle muss man wütend klingen und so was,
das ist nicht so, das wird tatsächlich,
das wird tatsächlich eher schwierig werden.
Also, hat sich viel getan, aber ich denke, man darf bezweifeln,
ob das, wie es jetzt zur Zeit angenommen wird von vielen Leuten,
dass das quasi noch höher und noch schneller geht, alles,
das darf man zumindest mal hinterfragen, ja.
Ich bin da skeptisch und das halt auch anhand der Beispiele
hier mit Mondlandung und Intel CPU Roadmap.
Ich denke, es wird sich auf jeden Fall weiterentwickeln,
und es wird sich auch schnell weiterentwickeln,
aber dieses, es geht exakt mindestens mal in diesem Tempo weiter,
nur wahrscheinlich noch viel explosionsartiger und schneller,
das kann man mal zumindest in Frage stellen,
ob das wirklich die nächsten 20 Jahre noch so weitergehen wird.
Leute, wir haben Probleme, das nächste Jahr und die nächsten zwei Jahre zu prädikten.
Halbwegs. Gut.
Und ich glaube auch, dass das keiner, auch von den ganzen Experten,
die sich aktuell zum Thema KI äußern,
wirklich keiner so richtig gut prädikten kann.
Also, was ich persönlich denke, ist, dass das weitergehen wird,
auch relativ rasant weitergehen wird,
aber dass es sich auch zunehmend im Detail verbessern wird.
Weil das ist halt das Ding, wenn man sagt, man hat jetzt was zu 80% erreicht,
die letzten 20% zu erreichen, also jedes weitere Prozent danach,
wird unglaublich viel schwerer.
Was zu 80% gut hinzukriegen, kein Ding.
Was zu 90% besser hinzukriegen, schon deutlich schwerer.
Was zu 95% dann zu verbessern, die letzten 5%, nochmal sehr viel schwerer.
Und dann jedes weitere Prozent ist enorm viel schwieriger.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass viele Verbesserungen der nächsten Jahre auch
ein bisschen im Detail liegen werden.
Was dann dazu führen könnte, dass die Sprünge, obwohl sie da sind,
aber nicht mehr so aussehen wie Sprünge,
sondern dass es vielen Leuten vielleicht gar nicht mehr so sehr auffällt,
dass sich das weiterhin verbessert.
Nehmen wir mal das Beispiel CPUs.
CPUs hat sich die letzten Jahre über kaum was getan, wenn man sich das anguckt,
so im Heimbereich, wie viele Kerne hat man, wie sind die Taktraten.
Aber trotzdem sind die CPUs schneller geworden.
Aber man sieht das nicht mehr so unbedingt auf den ersten Blick,
anhand von wie viele Kerne habe ich und welche Taktraten habe ich.
Das hat sich kaum verändert, CPUs sind trotzdem schneller geworden.
Aber nicht mehr so krass schneller,
wie wenn man sich das in den 90ern oder Anfang 2000er Jahren anguckt.
Und deswegen könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es gerade aus dem Gesichtspunkt,
weil sich eben trotzdem noch was tun wird und auch signifikant was tun wird,
es für viele Leute vielleicht nicht mehr so als riesen Sprung aussieht, wie jetzt.
Und zum Beispiel, wenn man sich Text-to-Speech anguckt,
weil das ist ja auch im Video vorhanden,
wenn man sich Text-to-Speech anguckt von vor ein paar Jahren zu jetzt,
da liegen Welten dazwischen, Lichtjahre liegen da dazwischen,
von Microsoft SAM zu Text-to-Speech, KI generiert von heute.
Und ich denke, dass das die nächsten Jahre über auch noch besser werden wird.
Aber wird das einem so viel krass besser vorkommen, wie die letzten paar Jahre?
Das bezweifle ich halt.
Ich glaube, der Unterschied wird einfach nicht mehr so extrem wahrnehmbar sein.
In vielen Bereichen. Es gibt auch neue Gebiete, die sich das Ganze dann erschließt.
Und ich gehe auch übrigens davon aus, dass Chat-GPT weiter halluzinieren wird.
Vielleicht weniger grob und weniger offensichtlich,
wie es das jetzt schon macht.
Ob man das dann halt als großen Fortschritt noch wahrnimmt, sei mal dahingestellt.
Was sagt ihr dazu, Chat? Ich habe jetzt lange geschwätzt.
Alles klar.
Muss ich jetzt mal loswerden.
Ja.
Also ich denke, in die Richtung wird es sich entwickeln.
Letztendlich, ich kann das genauso wenig prädikten, wie irgendjemand anderes.
Ich habe übrigens gerade Updates gemacht. Warum mache ich gerade nochmal Updates?
Cloud ist doch auch so ein Beispiel.
Da verstehe ich den Zusammenhang jetzt weniger.
Es gibt übrigens, habe ich schon gesehen, es gibt ein Chat-GPT-Connector für Kubernetes,
der da ein Cluster administriert.
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Man muss nicht unbedingt alles machen, was geht, oder?
Das hat 5000 Sterne.
Moment, ist das überhaupt das, was ich meine?
Hä?
Achso, nee, das meinte ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich meinte etwas anderes.
Vielleicht haben sie auch umgehauen.
Also, man muss nicht unbedingt alles machen, was geht.
Ja, aber das stimmt schon.
Aber was hat das mit AI-Entwicklung zu tun?
Benutzt du CodePython?
Ich habe das ausprobiert.
Ich habe das mal ausprobiert, als es noch kostenlos war.
Das ist cool, aber nicht so, dass ich da jetzt ein Abo für abschließen würde.
Da sind die Leute noch so ein bisschen zweigeteilt.
Manche schwören komplett drauf.
Und manche sagen, wozu soll ich das verwenden?
Ich kenne kaum einen, der sagt, ja, ab und zu nehme ich es mal, aber meistens nicht oder so.
Also, ich habe kein Abo abgeschlossen für.
Ich fand das schon cool, aber nichts, wo ich jetzt gesagt habe, oh ja, das brauche ich unbedingt.
Wenn man jetzt viel Boilerplate auskotzen muss, dann ist das bestimmt ganz praktisch.
Wo wir wieder dabei sind, dass AI als erstes wahrscheinlich Bullshit-Shops ersetzen wird.
Haben wir uns, ja, GitHub Trends haben wir uns schon angeguckt.
HomeLab Nightmares, too much stuff.
Also, wenn ich mir das so angucke, würde ich sagen, oh, Noctua-Lüfter, beste.
Naja, wenn man nicht so hohe Stromkosten hat, sieht das doch noch ganz überschaubar aus.
Wenn man ordentliche Stromkosten, also wenn man Stromkosten hat wie in Deutschland, dann ist es too much.
Weil ich sehe hier vorneweg schon mal, dass da unten ist einfach ein Schrank, oder?
Das ist keine USV.
Ich glaube, das ist einfach nur ein Schrank.
Ich sehe hier schon mal zwei USVs, eine NAS, eins, zwei NUCs, zwei HE-Server, ein HE-Server, irgendein UniFi-Gedöns, Patchpanel, Strom und nochmal eine 4 HE-Kiste.
Ja, das ist schon ganz schön overkill.
Und hier neben übrigens nochmal eine USV.
Ja, aber was ich gesehen habe, was ich mir jetzt eigentlich angucken wollte, ist die Kiste mit den Noctua-Lüftern drin.
Ja.
So ähnlich sah das in meiner 4 HE-Kiste auch aus.
Die ich nicht mehr habe.
Weil die einfach zu hart im Stromverbrauch war für so wenig, wie sie gemacht hat.
Kommt immer drauf an, wie viel Strom...
Wie viel man für Strom bezahlt.
Was ist das hier?
Mein Neo Wim und T-Max Terminal.
Oh, nee, nee, nee.
Okay, okay.
Was?
Erliebtag.
Hahaha.
Das ist nicht wahr.
Alter, was für ein Scheiß.
Hahaha.
Was für ein Scheiß.
Das Beste war der Ende.
Haha.
Das Beste war das Ende hier.
Von...
Das ist so cool.
Guck mir die Buff-Map.
Hahaha.
Robots, Stitching, hoffentlich nicht mit
AI, please.
Hört sich gar nicht mal so schlecht an.
Es hört sich genauso an, wie
ich es von AI-generierter Musik erwarten würde.
Okay.
Das war ja geil, ey.
Ist das auch AI-generierte Musik im Hintergrund?
So, Chat-GPT,
generiere mir ein paar Sekunden
Sound für ein
Robots, Stitching,
ein Korn,
Micro-Sturchery-Assistant-
Technical-Video.
Ohne Scheiß, die Musik könnte
AI-generiert sein.
Wo kam der Faden her?
Der Faden war auf einmal da.
Sass.
Kein Faden?
Faden. Sehr sass.
Wo kommt der Faden her?
Hätten die das irgendwie
hinkriegen, hätte der Roboter das hingekriegt?
Sieht man wo?
Da ist...
Leute, Leute.
Ah, Chat.
Ich meine nicht, wo.
Wo kommt der Faden...
Wie kommt der Faden da rein?
Wie hat es den Faden da durchgekriegt?
Ne?
Das meine ich doch.
Nicht, dass da irgendwo ein Faden liegt.
Das ist ja...
Aber die zeigen es nicht.
Die zeigen es nicht.
Ich wette mit euch, hätte das gut geklappt,
mit diesem Nadel da durch,
hätten die das gezeigt.
Das hat bestimmt nicht gescheit funktioniert.
Ich kriege irgendwie ein...
Wenn ich dieses Instrument und dieses Ding sehe,
kriege ich irgendwie so ein bisschen so Matrix-Vibes.
Äh...
Was bin ich jetzt sehend?
Was sehe ich da jetzt?
Ah, er steuert das hier.
Warum baut Sony sowas?
Weil Sony das kann.
Anscheinend.
Er steuert das hier.
Ja, jetzt verstehe ich das.
Okay.
Ja, das ist nice, oder?
Der Trend ging ja die letzten Jahre über schon hin,
dass man das alles...
Wie nennt sich das?
Minimal-Invasiv.
Minimal-Invasiv macht.
Also, dass man eben nix mehr aufschneidet,
sondern nach Möglichkeiten halt nur ein kleines Loch macht
und dann da sein Zeug reinschiebt.
Und operiert.
Und dann so, dass es keine großen Verletzungen gibt.
Ist doch nice.
Umso schonender man was operiert...
Ich meine, kosten wird das Ding wahrscheinlich unglaublich viel,
sodass du dir das als gesetzlich Versicherter
wahrscheinlich dich damit nicht behandeln lassen kannst.
Weil wir haben ja kein
Zwei-Klassen-Gesundheitssystem oder sowas
in Deutschland mehr haben.
Und...
Sagen die Leute zumindest,
wenn man sie danach fragt.
Aus meiner Sicht haben wir das schon.
Siehst du ja allein schon,
bei Wartezeiten,
rufen wir mal einen Hautarzt an und sagen,
ey, ich hab da irgendwie
ne Entzündung auf dem Kopf.
Das müsste ich mal eine auf der Kopfhaut,
das müsste ich mal eine angucken.
Dann sagen die so, ja, ja, in sechs Monaten können sie kommen.
Sagst du, ja, übrigens, ich bin privatversichert.
Ah, wie passt's morgen? Reicht das morgen noch?
Einer ab 1. August.
Alter, hust du aus.
So.
Ja, gibt's, gibt's ja schon
ein gescheites Video zur neuen
JavaScript-Registry.
Das Einzige, was ich da mitbekommen habe
bisher von ist, dass es
Native TypeScript-Support hat.
Tech Talk Recaps.
Leute, das ist AI-generiert.
Wollen wir wetten? Wollen wir wetten, dass das AI-generiert ist?
Der Typ hat einfach nur den Talk zusammengeschnitten.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht
als Übersicht, glaube ich.
NPM was built a long time ago.
You know, 14 years ago.
Ich finde die Präsentation von ihm immer übelst anstrengend.
Deswegen, ich hab das auch nach 5 Minuten.
Der ist wirklich
Pfeiffer, das ist der Node.js-Erfinder, by the way.
Aber ich finde die Präsentation
von ihm immer sehr anstrengend zu gucken.
Dann will ich nicht wissen,
wie lange du gebraucht hättest, in der gleichen Praxis
als gesetzlich versichert
einen Termin zu bekommen.
Und jetzt rate ich mal,
du bist zu einer Praxis gegangen, die gar keine
gesetzlich versichert nimmt.
Und weil, wenn das eine Bekannte ist,
dann ist natürlich da auch der Antrag ein bisschen höher.
Achso, hast du ja geschrieben.
Hast du ja sogar geschrieben.
What?
It's your girl?
Okay.
Wie heißt das Ding?
JSR.
JavaScript Registry.
Wir können uns doch einfach mal den Intro...
Duesing. 1. März schon, ja.
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
Also was ich mitbekommen habe, ist,
dass der Node.js-Erfinder,
beziehungsweise der Deno-Erfinder,
eine neue Package Registry
rausbringen will,
rausgebracht hat.
Als Konkurrenz,
beziehungsweise, so wie er das nennt,
als Ergänzung zu NPM.
Der Unterschied ist,
und das ist das, was ich in diesen ersten
fünf Minuten gesehen habe, der Unterschied ist,
dass Native TypeScript supportet wird.
Mehr weiß ich dazu auch nicht.
Gucken wir mal, ob Hacker News dazu einen Post hat.
Aha, Hacker News hat einen Post dazu.
Ansonsten, keine Ahnung.
Wir werden es uns bei Gelegenheit irgendwann mal anschauen,
wobei ich ehrlich gesagt noch nie ein NPM-Package published habe.
Muss ich aber auch nicht.
Es gibt genug Leute, die NPM-Packages publishen.
Und es werden ja solche Schwachsinn-NPM-Packages published, Leute.
NPM ist mittlerweile voll mit
Spam-Packages.
Ist euch das eigentlich mal aufgefallen?
Chat, wem ist das schon mal aufgefallen?
Wer macht viel mit NPM und JavaScript?
Ist euch auch schon mal aufgefallen,
dass NPM voll ist mit irgendwelchen Spam-Packages?
Mit Spam-Packages meine ich...
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das meine ich.
Das ist ja noch ernsthafter JavaScript-Sourcecode.
Auch wenn es...
Nee, das meine ich nicht.
Es gibt Spam-Packages.
Zum Beispiel, hier könnt ihr die neuesten Animes angucken.
Und sowas.
Echte Spam-Packages gibt es in NPM in letzter Zeit immer mehr.
Richtig viele.
Ja, hier könnt ihr die neuesten Kinofilme runterladen,
die neuesten Animes gucken.
Was weiß ich, hier gibt es die neuesten,
vor allem Workstation-Keys, whatever.
Ich wähle für den JavaScript-Package,
was einfach nur NOT heißt.
Und der ganze Sourcecode besteht aus dem Ausrufezeichen.
Was haltet ihr davon?
Ich finde, das ist eine gute Idee.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es das Package schon gibt?
Was meint ihr, gibt es das Package schon?
Oder ist das zu kurz?
Darf man das gar nicht registrieren?
JavaScript, Alter.
Sourcecode dazu müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Es ist genau das, was ich gesagt habe, Mann.
Fucking shit, Alter.
JavaScript.
Es ist ein Package, das heißt NOT.
Und das Einzige, was das macht,
ist ein Ausrufezeichen enthalten.
Alter.
JavaScript.
Boah.
Dieses Ökosystem.
Das macht mich fertig.
Es hat einfach, ey,
Das läuft mir in die Nase davon, ey.
Und es hat einfach mal
276.000
weekly downloads.
Okay, es hat selber keine dependencies.
Aber, aber es dependen,
aber es dependen immerhin
7 weitere Packages darauf, ja?
Und zwar
NOT NOT
NOT NOT NOT
Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Oder meine Güte.
Chainstream.
Es muss hier nur ein halbwegs semi-verbreitetes Package drin sein.
Und schon wird das alles mitgezogen.
Das Ding hat auch nicht mal einen Source-Code.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
NotNot.js
Return NotNot.
Excellent.
Beste.
Kann man sich NotNot nicht sparen?
Wie, du meinst einfach gar nichts verwenden davon?
Nee, das ist nicht der NPM-Way.
Nicht der JavaScript-Way.
Und NotNotNot gibt es auch noch.
Okay, also.
Ich predikte mal.
Das Package ist ernst gemeint.
Die anderen Packages ist getrollt.
Ja, gehe ich auch von aus.
Ja, also ich gehe davon aus, dass NotNot und NotNotNot, dass das gebetet ist.
Aber das hier ist, glaube ich, ernst gemeint.
Gibt es sogar Issues?
Really?
Ach, ja.
Ja, was gibt's?
Ich vermute mal, es gibt irgendwie so einen Complete Dependency List für NPM-Package.
Weiß ich aber nicht wie.
Also so einen Dependency-Tree-Dings gibt es bestimmt.
Dass du quasi alle Packages listen kannst, die abhängig sind von dem einen Package.
Und dann wiederum alle Packages, die von diesen Packages abhängig sind und dann wieder von diesen.
Weil ich meine, irgendwie, irgendwie muss dieses Ding ja auf...
Auf 276.000 Downloads kommen.
Chat, wie würdet ihr das handhaben?
Mal angenommen, ihr bräuchtet so eine Funktion, wie das NotNPM bereitstellt.
Würdet ihr dann eine Dependency auf das Not-Package machen?
Oder einfach zwei Zeilen zusätzlich bei euch in den Source-Code reinschreiben, um das selbst zu definieren?
Also ich würde es auf jeden Fall ohne Abhängigkeit machen und einfach die zwei Zeilen selbst reinschreiben.
Also wenn ich anstatt so Not irgendwas schreiben möchte, aus irgendwelchen Gründen, warum auch immer ich das machen will, fällt mir aktuell noch nicht so richtig ein, dann würde ich die zwei Zeilen reinkopieren.
Das ist eigentlich the way.
Das ist eigentlich the way, ja.
Weil dadurch, dass du die Dependency auf Not-Not-Not machst, hast du Not-Not und Not auch mit dabei.
Du hast dann zwar drei unsinnige Dependencies, aber kann man so machen.
Wie oft will ich denn heute noch Package-Updates machen?
So, was macht der Dude denn?
Oh, ein Westerm-Enjoyer.
Okay, das Video müssen wir uns angucken.
Der weiß anscheinend, wie es geht.
Ein Westerm-Enjoyer, nice.
Endlich mal.
Kriegt das ein bisschen Exposure.
Ich benutze das seit einer ganzen Weile schon.
Westerm ist das Beste.
Okay.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
Mein Neo-Wim-End-Team-Mind.
Warum braucht er noch T-Mux, wenn er...
Westerm verwendet?
Das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich interessieren.
Irgendwie habe ich ein bisschen französische Vibes.
Wie schätzt...
Was denkt ihr über den Akzent?
Ich kann es nicht so richtig zuordnen.
Aber ich gette so ein leichte, leichte French-Vibes.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt weder großartig negativ,
so ich frage mich nur, woher kommt es vom Akzent her.
Es ist teilweise enorm schwierig zuzuordnen.
Nee, doch nicht französisch.
Vielleicht geht es nicht so leicht.
Also, wir werden es erst mal mit einem Überblick fangen,
von den Grundlagen an, und werden es langsam in Läden bauen,
bis zu jedem Teil, das ich verwende, um mein perfektes Umfeld zu gestalten.
Ich benutze Westerm.
Ich mag seine Einfügigkeit, seine Geschwindigkeit,
die Art, wie er Visuale von Icon-
Westerm, Beste.
... durch Emojis und so weiter, die sich in der Terminale befinden.
Das ist Yazi, übrigens, die diese Dinge schön...
Spanisch, okay.
...inside Westerm zeigt.
Westerm ist super...
Was hat er da am Start?
Das ist Yazi, übrigens.
Yazi!
Aber warum?
Wir zeigen diese Dinge...
Das ist so ein Ding, es gibt zig dieser Terminal, wie nennt man das?
Es ist ja nicht mal ein File Manager.
Es gibt zig dieser Terminal Directory Browser Dinger.
Ich habe noch nie verstanden, warum man die Dinger verwendet.
Weil, was ist es für einen Vorteil, sich das hier drinnen anzugucken,
anstatt zu sagen, CD-Repos LS.
Ich verstehe, dass es cool aussieht, dass es nice, vielleicht auch umzeigen ist,
aber ist das wirklich weniger Tippen?
Du benutzt halt hier die Pfeiltasten und drückst Enter, bei dem anderen machst du CD, okay.
Das ist ein bisschen weniger Tippen.
Dafür hast du halt den Vorteil, du willst ja meistens dann auch irgendwas machen,
wenn du an deinem Ziel angekommen bist und dann brauchst du wieder eh dein Terminal,
um dort, was weiß ich, Git auszuführen, irgendwas zu öffnen und so.
Also, ich habe mir das schon ein paar Mal überlegt und ich bin, für mich habe ich noch nie erkannt,
was der Sinn von diesem Terminal File Manager ist.
Westram ist super easy to configure, it does everything I need,
it includes quick changes from time to time, when I adjust it for videos, like this one for example.
Midnight Commander ist ganz nice.
Wenn ich in gepackte Sachen reinschauen will, wenn ich in gepackte Sachen reinschauen will,
dann benutze ich Z-Less zum Beispiel.
Das kann eine gezippte Textdatei öffnen und mit Less durchscrollen.
Ja, aber ich verstehe schon, was du meinst.
In manchen Fällen mag es sinnvoll sein.
The look is minimal, nothing fancy and it fits every use case I have.
Here is a list of images where the folders and the image icons are nerd font rendered on the left.
Übrigens, sehr nice.
Er benutzt die Westram.
Westram Image Vorschau.
Es gibt tatsächlich nicht viele Terminals, die das gescheit implementiert haben.
Zum Beispiel hier.
Westram kann sogar GIFs anzeigen.
Animierte GIFs.
Da gibt es nicht viele Terminals, die das gescheit können.
Plus die drumherum nicht satten.
Kitty kann es auch, aber der Kitty Autor ist Weirdchamp.
While the images themselves are rendered in the terminal,
I used to run iTerm, then found Alacrity to be the best when it comes to Lean Solution.
Moved to Kitty for speed and landed on Westram as the best of all worlds.
Westram ist ohne Scheiß, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Westram ist das beste Terminal, was es zurzeit gibt unter Linux.
The others, it has its flaws, like the lack of native Windows Solution for Mac OS, for example.
But nothing I can deal with to be honest.
Wie das heißt, Westram, das ist mal...
Ja, Westram.
Nee.
Der Wetz hat das erstellt, deswegen ist es das Wetz-Term.
Ja, das da.
Falls du eine Minimal-Config brauchst, kannst du bei mir auf GitHub gucken.
Ich hab meinen...
Weil die minimalst outdated ist.
Ich hab meine...
Ups.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich hab meine Westram-Config hier.
Das Coole an Westram ist auch, die Config ist seine eigene Programmiersprache.
Also du kannst quasi...
Unter der Haube ist es Lua.
Du kannst quasi programmieren in deiner Terminal-Config.
Also das hier ist Westram.
Beste.
Ja, ich auch.
Ich versteh's auch nicht.
Ich find's auch unnötig.
To be honest, since I've been asked a ton of times and the font Westram uses is JetBrains Mono.
And although GitHub are trying to compete with that with a new set of coding fonts...
Hab ich auch ausprobiert?
Ich hab schon.
Ich hab fast alle.
Okay, den hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Github Monaspace.
Der gefällt mir aber auch schon nicht.
Der da oben sieht noch am angenehmsten aus.
Also...
Ich hab fast alle Fonts durch.
So relativ bekannte Mono Space Fonts.
Und ich kann mir einfach nichts helfen.
Ich bleib immer wieder beim gleichen Font hängen.
Und zwar ist das hier Hack.
Nee.
Gekauft habe ich keine Fonts.
Das ist den Font, den verwende ich seit Jahren schon.
Und...
Und ich bleib irgendwie immer wieder da drauf hängen.
Und ich find den einfach insgesamt am stimmigsten.
Das ist aber eine sehr subjektive Sache.
Hat jeder so seins.
Gut, hab ich auch.
Ja.
Ich auch.
Ich bin billig.
Starship Enjoyer.
Ich mag den Kerl.
Mein Prompt ist auch mit Starship.
Der weiß, wie es geht hier.
Hack wird nicht mal weiterentwickelt.
Chatge, was ist mit meiner Leiste hier unten los?
Das sieht ein bisschen kaputt aus, oder?
Ah, okay.
Windows hat sich selbst wieder gefixt.
Vielleicht gibt es einfach nichts weiter zu entwickeln.
Narrow People's Set.
Das ist ein Font.
Litties.
Nein, benutze ich nicht.
Benutze ich nicht.
Ich auch.
Hat jemand so ein Split-Keyboard?
Ich nicht.
Ich mag sowas nicht.
Opa, hier hat er gar kein Split-Keyboard.
Hier hat er so ein Mini-Keyboard.
Mag ich auch nicht.
Da bin ich sehr oldschool.
Ich habe ein ganz normales
Full-Size-Keyboard.
Mit NumBlock und allem.
Ich mag auch NumBlocks.
Diese Minimal-Dinger
sind nicht meins.
Starship ist vor allem written in rust.
Ich wusste, dass das kommt.
... Charme to work with.
I've got a lot of videos covering both my old ways
with OhMyZSH,
but an even more recent one covering
when I moved to Starship,
the whys, the hows,
and I highly recommend it.
You can see how Starship helps with my git status.
It offers even deeper dive
when I'm rebasing or cherrypicking.
It can detect my AWS account region and profile.
Kann ich auch nur empfehlen.
Was ich bei Starship auch ganz cool finde ist,
erstens, dass es,
wenn man da mal durchblickt,
recht gut,
das muss ich auch mal ausschalten hier,
recht gut customizable ist.
Ich hab beispielsweise auch hier
den Prompt customized,
dass es ein zweizeiliger Prompt ist.
Ich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Wie sieht's bei ihm eigentlich aus?
Aha, er ist ein Einzeilen-Prompt-Enjoyer.
Arbeitet er was oder konfiguriert
er nur sein Terminal?
Das hängt zusammen.
Ich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Der hauptsächliche Grund,
warum ich zweizeilige Prompts mag,
ist, dass sich nix verschiebt
und dass die Sachen immer an der
gleichen Stelle bleiben.
Wenn ich jetzt hier zum Beispiel mal
in irgendwas tiefgenestetes reingehe,
dann steht das hier oben drinnen
mit dem Pfad.
Oh, mein Terminal ist broken.
Muss ich mal
das Icon austauschen anscheinend.
Warum ist das?
Das können wir grad mal fixen.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist
das gar nicht.
Wo ist das kaputt?
Ach geht,
Branch ist kaputt.
Okay, warum?
Was war das denn mal für ein ursprüngliches
Symbol hier?
Was habe ich denn da gemacht?
Unicode Characters.
Was war das denn mal?
Okay, das
war bestimmt nicht so
gedacht. Irgendwie
ist das ein bisschen kaputt.
Na gut.
Gibt es da ein schönes
Symbol für?
Da gibt es doch so
eine Seite.
Cheat, cheat, cheat.
Branch.
Easy.
Ja, jetzt sieht es schon wieder deutlich besser aus.
Ich mach mal hier das
Leerzeichen weg.
Easy clap.
Okay, da sieht es doch schon wieder besser aus.
Ja, also der Grund, warum ich zweizeilige
Prompts mag, ist, dass
meine Zeile
dort, wo ich tippe, immer an der gleichen Stelle
anfängt. Egal, wie tief
ich in irgendeiner Directory-Struktur
drinnen bin und auch, ne,
dadurch, dass es, dann
verschiebt sich das nicht so schnell. Stellt euch mal vor,
mein Terminal wäre nur so breit und ich würde jetzt
hier tippen oder so. Das ist doof.
Deswegen, ich mag zweizeilige Prompts.
Aber da hat jeder so seine Vorliebe für.
Ich find's cool, dass er auch Starship verwendet.
Und dass er auch nicht so 3 Milliarden
ZSH-Plugins
verwendet, sondern eine relativ schlanke Config.
Also der, der weiß, was er macht.
Ich find das lustig, gell?
Bei Videos und so, wo irgendjemand
das macht, wie ich das mache, sagt jemand, ey, der hat
Ahnung, der weiß, was er macht.
Letztendlich kann's jeder machen,
wie's ihm gefällt.
Gibt's da ein Wallpaper irgendwie zum runterladen?
Klar, du kannst sogar hier
Ups, kriegst
sogar alle. Hier, guck mal auf GitHub.
Da sind alle Varianten
davon.
Inklusive einem
Background-Wechsel-Skript, wobei man das
nicht verwenden muss, der passend zur
Tageszeit das ganze
die Stimmung setzt.
Das ist noch das
In 10 Minuten
switcht er, glaub ich, um auf den Mittags-Wallpaper.
Also gibt's
mehrere. Es gibt mehrere
zu jeder Tageszeit.
Du hast für mittags,
ist er am Futtern,
ist er am Arbeiten,
Lötchampen,
Booster trinken,
Chat. Heute gibt es
tatsächlich
Nudeln mit Lachs,
Bügeln, Gewichte heben,
Template-Vorlage,
Bücher lesen,
vor allem was für eins,
dann Essen,
Kaffee trinken, Frühstück futtern.
Ach, die Croissants sind zweimal drin.
Einmal mit Dampfkaffee und einmal
mit Java-Kaffee und einmal ohne, verstehe.
Oh, da schläft er.
Zähne putzen.
Videos gucken.
Du hast ein Bügeleisen.
Ich hab ein Bügeleisen, ja, aber
ich meine nur, weil auf so einem Bild
ein Pepo drauf ist, der ein Bügeleisen hat,
heißt es nicht unbedingt, dass ich zwangsläufig
trink zum Beispiel auch keine Booster.
Keine Energydrinks.
Ach ja, und das was der
Ragman gerade schreibt,
er hat ja die Bilder erstellt.
Wie ihr hier seht, sind alle von ihm.
Steht auch hier drinnen.
Wenn ihr Ideen habt für weitere
Pepo-Bilder,
könnt ihr euch bei ihm im Discord melden.
Und wenn er Bock hat,
gibt's vielleicht bald
eure Pepo-Background-Idee
hier auf GitHub.
Ein Großteil der Dinger kam, glaube ich,
sogar nachträglich noch dabei.
Hackerman-Pepo.
Ja, wir haben ja schon ein Arbeits-Pepo.
Vielleicht, vielleicht
Pepo mit Katze streicheln.
Ja, gute Idee, gute Idee.
Also vielleicht ist ja irgendwas dabei,
was dich inspiriert.
So sieht's aus.
Gut, da machen wir mal
das Video weiter.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss.
Ich verwende keinen TMAX mehr lokal und wisst ihr, warum ich keinen TMAX mehr lokal-
Worum ich mein- lokal auf dem Server?
Selbstverständlich, nach wie vor oder Remote.
Das liegt daran, weil Westterm
auch alles so gut wie alles kann, was
TMAX, was ich von TMAX
verwendet hab. Guck.
Ich kann splitten, horizontal
und vertikal, ich kann rein und raus
zoomen, also das hier jetzt vergrößern,
verkleinern.
Ich kann die Sachen sogar mit der Maus verschieben,
was bei TMAX so ohne weiteres nicht funktioniert.
funktioniert. Was verwendet man
von TMAX denn sonst noch so
öfters?
Ja, verschiedene Sessions.
Tabs aufmachen.
Auch kein Problem. Es sieht
vor allem auch ein bisschen aus wie TMAX,
ne, hier unten. Habe ich absichtlich
so konfiguriert, aber es ist nicht TMAX.
Es ist rein Westterm,
was das hier macht. Und ein
Riesenvorteil versus TMAX ist,
dass Westterm checkt,
dass das hier unterschiedliche Fenster
sind. Oder unterschiedliche
Terminal-Panels.
TMAX checkt das nicht. Zum Beispiel,
wenn ihr bei TMAX jetzt,
ja,
sagen wir mal, ihr wollt copy-pasten
diese Zeile bei TMAX,
dann würdet ihr mit
TMAX alles copy-pasten,
inklusive dieser Seite hier.
Habe ich so auch noch installiert?
Ja, guck, ich zeige es euch mal.
Wenn ich bei TMAX jetzt die Zeile
hier markieren will, ne,
dann geht das nicht. Oder die 2 muss ich,
seht ihr? TMAX weiß nämlich
nicht, dass das 2
unterschiedliche, oder das Terminal weiß nicht,
dass das 2 unterschiedliche
Splits sind.
Ja, Copy-Mode ist, ach, das ist
abartig.
Ich will copy-pasten ordentlich mit dem Maus,
das ist super hakelig. Ja, der Copy-Mode
suckt.
Aber man sieht schon den Unterschied, wie praktisch
das ist, dass das Terminal
das checkt. Es gibt ein paar Sachen,
die kann TMAX besser.
Ja, aber wie?
Ich habe das auch schon ausprobiert. Ich weiß, dass das mit der Maus
geht. Du kannst beispielsweise
da drinnen auch nur super hakelig mit dem
Mausrad rauf und runter scrollen, während
du die Maustaste gedrückt hältst und sowas.
Das ist echt so ein
super behelfsmäßiges Ding. Ich mag
Copy-Mode gar nicht. Was hältst
du von ST als
Terminal? Das ist mir zu
minimalistisch. So.
Und das ist halt nice an WestTerm,
wenn du die Splits hast, weil das Terminal
weiß, dass das hier quasi ein eigenes Terminal-
Fenster ist. Da hast du die ganzen Probleme
nicht. Maus funktioniert ohne Probleme,
Copy-Paste, gedrückt halten, scrollen,
Funks ohne Probleme. Ich kann hier oben anfangen, hier runter
scrollen und es ist dann immer noch drüber.
Wunderbar. Ja. Also das
finde ich tatsächlich deutlich angenehmer als das
mit TMAX. Wenn ich mich per SSH
auf irgendein System verbinde,
dann immer noch TMAX. Und wenn ich was haben will,
was auf irgendeiner Remote-Kiste
auch beim Disconnect
nicht abkacken soll, dann auch
TMAX. Aber bei mir lokal
kein TMAX mehr. Weil ich
einfach nichts davon vermisse,
was TMAX hat, was ich
irgendwie mit Westterm nachgebaut bekommen hab.
Maus im Terminal nicht sehr
Hackerman. Ja, das mag sein.
Aber ich frag mich halt, wie coole
Hackermans beispielsweise
sowas selecten wollen.
So schnell, wie ich das mit der Maus mache.
Ja. Ich weiß, es gibt
die Möglichkeit, man kann den Copy-Mode
anmachen. Man kann in
den IMAX oder WIM
Selection-Mode wechseln.
Und dann kann man sagen,
Forward-M, Leertaste
drücken. Aber ganz ehrlich,
da musst du schon
ein richtig krasser IMAX- oder WIM-Hackerman
sein, dass du das so schnell hinkriegst, wie ich
diesen Bereich gerade mit der Maus selected hab.
Und Windows.
Wenn du dich erinnerst, habe ich dir am Anfang gesagt,
dass einige der Software, die ich benutze,
ihre Blindspots haben. Und das hat mich mit
meiner eigenen Open Source-Sichtung geschlossen.
TMAX Sessions ist ein solcher Spot.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich Session X bilde.
Und mit anderen tollen Beitragern
arbeite ich weiter und genieße es.
Session X wird in der Video-App
hier genauer gespielt.
Okay, das ist das der Automatik-Symbol.
Der Automatik-Symbol startet, wenn er einen Terminal aufmacht.
Ja, das ist ganz cool.
Ich habe auch mal vor Jahren
mit so einem TMAX-Session-Manager
rumgespielt.
Ich fand es übersichtlich.
Manch einer würde sagen, bloatet.
Aber
ich meine, eigentlich ist ja sogar,
wenn man mal ehrlich ist, Chat,
eigentlich ist sogar GUI bloatet, oder?
Fullscreen
Oldschool 80-Zeilen-Terminal.
Wobei, 80?
Nee, 40.
Wir reduzieren einfach bloat.
Wer braucht schon eine grafische Oberfläche, Mann?
Keine Maus, kein Browser,
einfach nur Text Oldschool.
Vim Visual Mode.
Der Chat sagt gerade,
Vim Visual Mode ist der Endgegner.
Ich finde, Vim Visual Mode ist enorm praktisch,
wenn man weiß,
wo ist es denn hier?
Wenn man weiß, dass man mit,
ich zeige es euch mal,
es gibt ein paar Sachen für Vim Visual Mode.
Es gibt V in Vim.
Damit kannst du,
ganze Sachen selecten,
so, so wie man das kennt.
Dann gibt es
Shift-V.
Damit selectet man ganze Zeilen, ja?
Und jetzt kommt es.
Es gibt Control-V.
Damit selectet man vertikal.
Ich glaube, hier oben sieht man es,
hier oben sieht man es besser.
Und Shift-V ist super praktisch,
um zum Beispiel
Textdateien, Copy-Paste-Sachen aufzuräumen.
Wenn ihr irgendwas copy-pasted habt
und beispielsweise was gerne passiert,
dass Leute Zeilennummern
mit copy-pasten
und die wollen Zeilennummern löschen,
dann geht ihr einfach dahin,
skaliert diagonal genau und sagt hier,
ah, eigentlich wollen wir das nicht,
zack, weg damit.
Also, Shift-V, Zeile, Control-V.
Also im Prinzip könnte man eigentlich sagen,
Shift-V horizontal,
Control-V vertikal
und normales V halt so,
wie man es kennt, selecten.
Ja, und Session Manager brauche ich nicht.
Wenn ich beispielsweise was programmieren will,
dann läuft das bei mir so,
ich gehe hier hin,
ich starte meine IDE
und ich starte mir beispielsweise,
machen wir jetzt mal irgendwas auf,
hier so das da, ne,
so, und dann starte ich mir einfach ein Terminal,
schiebe mir das nebenhin
und gehe ins Verzeichnis, wo ich rein will
und gut ist.
Ja, das dauert jetzt 20 Sekunden,
aber das mache ich einmal am Tag
oder zwei-, dreimal am Tag, wenn es hochkommt,
nicht so schlimm.
Ich habe damit auch vor ein paar Jahren rumgespielt,
brauche ich, habe ich, war nichts für mich dabei.
Wo ich gesagt habe, ja,
so ein Session Manager bräuchte ich.
Ach so, das ist so eine Sessionsuchbox.
Also ich habe tatsächlich,
ich glaube, Westerm kann sogar unterschiedliche Sessions.
Habe ich nicht.
Ich persönlich komme mit Tabs aus.
Sessions brauche ich nur auf dem Server,
wenn man beispielsweise sagt,
ey, wir connecten uns mal kurz dahin,
zusammen machen eine Debug Session auf
und connecten uns mit TMAX an das Gleiche
und ich habe vorher schon mal irgendwas gestartet,
ja, aber Sessions lokal für TMAX
habe ich eigentlich nie gebraucht.
Ich habe die, ich habe die auch alle customised
und habe im Prinzip die Keybindings,
die ich in TMAX customised hatte,
habe ich jetzt in Westerm nachgebaut.
Und wie gesagt, für mich funktioniert das lokal
ohne TMAX viel besser.
It's fairly easy to get started with
and if you feel it's too much to take,
go ahead and give Zelige a quick test.
Oh, ne.
I've got another version,
I've got another video
covering everything around Zelige,
Das kenne ich.
Ich habe für mich aber entschieden,
nope, weil lokal brauche ich es nicht.
Da mache ich mit Westerm alles,
was ich machen will.
Und auf dem Server gibt es es eh nicht.
Also.
But why?
... right up here.
In terms of terminal-based tooling,
before I head over to my highlight,
among a bunch of others,
here are my top CLIs
that I cannot live without.
Ok.
Zoxite to begin with,
which is a modern raster alternative
to the famous
Das ist cool.
Das ist so ein Ding, was ich tatsächlich mal ausprobieren würde
und mir vorstellen könnte, dass es mir gefällt.
Ach, jetzt geht der Edit.
Vielleicht können wir das nachher mal ausprobieren.
Ich habe aber was ähnliches.
Also sagen wir mal, ich gehe jetzt hier dahin
und dann wechsle ich dahin.
Ich kann jetzt einfach 1 drücken
und dann gehe ich wieder ins letzte Verzeichnis.
2, 3, 4, 5.
Also ich war jetzt noch in keinem Verzeichnis,
aber so kann ich die durchwechseln.
Ja, okay, ich sehe nicht welches.
Das stimmt schon.
Ja, so kann ich immer die letzten 2 Verzeichnisse wechseln.
Das hat mir bis jetzt immer gereicht.
Dazu kommt, dass ich ja diese Autocomplete-Geschichte habe.
Also sprich, wenn ich sagen wir jetzt mal hier CD,
wenn ich dahin will,
muss ich einfach nur noch...
hier das Auto completen und komme da rein.
Alternativ sage ich halt Repos.
Ja, das da.
Okay, aha, will ich rein, Autocomplete.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob mir das so viel bringt
mit so einem smarten Directory-Switcher.
If you're unsure or you have multiple paths
with ambiguous solutions, it also integrates with FZF.
That will help.
FZF ist tatsächlich enorm POG.
Ich bin auch Steuerung-Air-Enjoyer, ja.
Meine Shell-History ist meine Dokumentation.
Ich schreibe nichts auf.
Ich habe einfach eine unendlich große Shell-History.
You achieve the destination that you wanted from the get-go.
Das ist mir alles zu fummelig.
Wenn ich für alles 50 Shortcuts habe und da und die...
Das ist mir... Benutzt du Ardui?
Ne, benutze ich auch nicht.
Das ist auch irgend so ein Command-Line-Switcher oder sowas.
Das ist diese Schildkröte, ist das.
Weil ich kenne das.
Ähm, ne.
By the way, if you read the documentation,
it goes through all the options and everything you need to know.
Beyond Zoxide, I use many modern alternatives,
which for some reason are all Rust-based, like FD...
Sinkt die Schelle? Ich habe mir das angeguckt.
Der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Aber...
Du meinst, Shell-History synkt zwischen verschiedenen Linux-Rechnern?
Will ich das haben?
Will ich meine Shell-History zwischen verschiedenen Linux-Rechnern synken?
Ja.
Eher nicht, oder?
Da steht ja durchaus mal vielleicht auch das ein oder andere in der History,
was du nicht überall verteilen möchtest.
Dog, Bat and Ezza.
Instead of CD, for example, I use a combination of CD and Ezza
to make everything more readable.
Äh, habe ich benutzt? Früher?
Benutze ich nicht mehr?
Ich benutze mittlerweile ganz normal...
LS wieder.
Ich habe, okay, ich habe das Alias, das immer colored.
Ja.
Ich benutze ganz normal oldschool LS mittlerweile.
Wieder.
Ich habe das auch mal eine ganze Weile benutzt.
Ich glaube, ich habe es sogar noch installiert.
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Eats.
Hatte ich auch mal.
Ist ganz nice.
Kann ein paar extra Sachen anzeigen.
Warum ich auf die Standard-Tools oftmals wieder zurückgeswitcht bin,
nachdem ich ein paar Alternativen ausprobiert habe, ist...
Das ist eigentlich der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich es gemacht habe
und warum ich es eigentlich auch jedem empfehlen kann,
ist, die Standard-Tools sind überall drauf.
Auf jedem Server, wo ihr euch connectet, ist ein LS drauf.
Ein WIM.
CD für Verzeichnisse und sowas.
Oder ein Temux zum Bedienen.
Ähm, und wenn man sich an zu viele rewritten in Rust Standard-Tools gewöhnt,
hat man irgendwann keine Ahnung mehr,
und vertippt sich die ganze Zeit.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt euch jetzt hier an ETSA gewöhnt,
und das hat beispielsweise so eine super nice Option.
Ich glaube, ich werde keine Option finden bei LS, die nicht schon belegt ist.
Und dann habt ihr euch daran gewöhnt, und ihr verwendet das immer,
und dann tippt ihr das automatisch auf dem Server,
und dann kommt danach, nee, gibt's ja nicht.
Deswegen verwende ich auch zum Editieren,
auf der Kommandozeile immer WIM,
ohne großartige Plugins und customizable Sachen.
Wenn ich was Größeres brauche, mache ich Rider oder irgendeine JetBrains IDE auf,
oder Visual Studio Code.
Meine WIM-Config ist halt auch ziemlich kurz und knackig.
Ja, ist nicht so viel drin.
Es heißt nicht, dass es nicht jede Menge cooler Tools gibt.
Bei den meisten habe ich festgestellt, für meinen Workflow ist es nicht unbedingt so nice,
oder nicht wert, sich umzustellen.
Und viele Sachen befände ich absichtlich nicht.
Gerade sowas hier.
Weil eines meiner täglichen Aufgaben ist ja,
remote aufs System eingeloggt zu sein,
und da was zu machen.
Und wenn ich mich dann jedes Mal im Kopf umschalten muss,
zwischen, es ist mein lokales LS, was die Option hat,
es ist das Red Hat LS, was die Option nicht hat,
und sowas, das ist mir zu blöd.
FD habe ich tatsächlich noch drauf.
FD ist in der Tat ganz nice.
Ich mache allerdings auch oftmals, stink noch mal,
das Find.
Ich muss einfach wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Ja, machen wir weiter.
FZF ist eines der wenigen Tools,
so Kommandozeilen-Tools,
die ich ausprobiert habe,
es sofort sinnvoll fand,
und seit Jahren regelmäßig benutze.
Also eines von diesen nicht-default-Kommandozeilen-Tools.
FZF ist mega praktisch.
FZF kannst du solche,
ich zeige euch mal ein Beispiel,
machen wir mal hier LS minus LA,
oder machen wir mal LS nach FZF,
und da kannst du jetzt hier drinnen suchen,
nach allem, was das enthält,
und du kriegst halt so eine Auswahlliste.
Du kannst quasi alles,
jegliche Textausgabe durchsuchbar machen,
und ich habe erst letztens auf der Arbeit,
und da kannst du es auswählen,
und da kannst du auch entscheiden, was damit sonst passiert,
ich habe erst letztens auf der Arbeit was gescriptet,
was von unserem Ansible Tower
alle Server-Inventories abruft,
die unsere Systeme betreffen,
und dann ein bisschen umkonfiguriert,
und nach FZF piped,
und dann kannst du dich jetzt per SSH connecten,
auf jegliches System,
innerhalb von zwei Sekunden,
top aktuell immer aus unserem Ansible Inventory.
Also du kannst jetzt einfach hier einkucken,
kekw, Server, suchst du aus,
bam, enter, ssh, login.
Und das geht so schnell,
und so easy,
das haben jetzt ein paar Leute bei mir,
ich habe es ja auch mal gezeigt,
aus dem Team schon gesehen,
und haben gesagt, Max, hier,
du musst unbedingt mal bei Git pushen,
ich will das auch verwenden.
Also für sowas ist FZF richtig geil.
Für so Autocomplete,
nee, nicht Autocomplete,
Quasi-Search,
Substring-Search,
das ist ja nicht reine Substring-Search,
FZF ist ja relativ clever,
da kannst du zum Beispiel schreiben,
vm, und bin,
und dann sucht er das, und das,
und zeigt das.
Also FZF ist sehr, sehr nice.
Hat, finde ich auch,
jeden Stern auf GitHub verdient hier.
Hat ja nur 60.000 Sterne.
Grepp, ohne Scheiß, Grepp.
Ich weiß, es gibt alternative Tools,
und ich weiß, die sind schneller als Grepp,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so,
als sucht man tagtäglich in einer Codebase,
die so groß ist wie der Linux-Körner,
und dann linear durch alles durch,
ohne dass du ein bisschen Ahnung hast, wo es ist.
In der Regel ist Grepp
schnell genug,
und das Schöne ist,
Grepp ist easy verskriptbar,
weil Grepp ist überall drauf.
Das heißt, Grepp-Optionen kennen
ist essentiell,
und ich verwende auch keine custom,
Grepp-Alternativen.
Das ist hier RG, das ist
Grepp-Grepp, heißt das Tool.
Ich hab das, ich hab das,
es ist nicht so, als hätte ich die Sachen nicht alle schon mal ausprobiert.
...G, as it's best in class,
and its speed will never disappoint you
when searching for text.
My CD-Alias, mentioned earlier, can be seen here,
and it's also on my .zshrc
on the .files repo.
L stands here as another alias
for ESA list, showing beautiful icons
and the git status.
Just to showcase some icons, and the git options,
check out how it looks.
Es sieht cool aus.
Ich gebe ihm rechts sein Terminal,
und es sieht alles cool aus.
Mir persönlich ist es zu fummelig und kleinteilig,
wenn ich das hier sehe.
Ich hab's auch schon mal ausprobiert,
mit Icons auf der,
ich find's einfach Informations-Overflow,
und es sieht cool aus,
aber es hat im Prinzip kaum Mehrwert.
Es rauscht einfach nur mehr,
deine Terminal-Ausgabe.
Durch die 3000 verschiedenen Farben,
durch die Images,
durch die Icons,
durch alles Mögliche.
Manchmal, gerade bei Terminal-Ausgaben,
ich leg ja schon Wert darauf,
dass es gescheit aussieht,
aber manchmal ist weniger,
was Terminal-Ausgabe ansieht,
tatsächlich mehr.
Ich finde das hier zum Beispiel,
die Ausgabe, viel viel übersichtlicher als das.
Tjetke, wie seht ihr das?
Also der Coolness-Faktor
ist eindeutig hier deutlich höher.
Aber von der Übersicht her
kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Das ist mir auch mit den Sessions
und der überallen Fuzzy-Search
viel zu fummelig.
Aber wie das so ist,
gerade Terminal-Config ist eine sehr individuelle Sache,
da mag das jeder ein bisschen anders.
Ich bin ja schon froh,
dass ich so modern bin,
Leute,
dass ich einen geblurrten,
halbtransparenten,
oder 95% nicht transparenten Hintergrund habe.
Ihr seht's vielleicht nicht,
aber wenn ihr mal genau hinguckt,
seht ihr im Hintergrund den Pepo durchgucken.
Den hier, guckt mal.
Seht ihr das?
Der Pepo guckt da leicht geblurrt
im Hintergrund durch.
So dezent, dass es kaum auffällt,
oder auch die Wolken hier oben.
Da bin ich ja schon super modern mit.
Ich hatte,
ich wollte das ja die ganze Zeit nie haben,
weil ich auch gesagt habe,
blurrte Terminal-Background ist bloat,
geh mal weg, braucht man nicht.
Kannst du das mit FZF,
Ansible, Tauern, SSH erklären,
bzw. was du da gemacht hast?
Ich kann das Skript sogar mal irgendwo pushen,
weil das nix
arbeitgeberspezifisches
enthält.
Ne, ne, ne, der ist noch gar nicht
bei Neowim angekommen.
Ja gut, du musst halt gucken,
werden die noch weiterentwickelt,
bzw. neue Optionen beim Update und so.
Also,
ich versuch das mal so ganz grob zu erklären.
Ansible Tower,
bzw. AAP,
bzw. AWX,
das Zeug heißt ja alles anders,
Ansible Tower, so hieß das früher mal,
heißt nicht mehr so.
Das heißt jetzt, Ansible
AWX
und die Business-Variante von
Ansible AWX, ehemalig Tower,
ist AAP.
Alles klar?
Letztendlich macht's aber auch keinen Unterschied,
weil die ne API haben.
Und über diese
API
kannst du Inventories abfragen.
Und wenn du weißt,
was für eine ID, bzw. welcher Name
dein Inventory hat,
dann kannst du dir alle
Inventories über Command Line
von deinem Ansible
Tower, bzw. AWX
Server ziehen.
Und wenn du alle Inventories hast, dann hast du
logischerweise alle Hosts, die bei dir gespeichert
sind im Tower.
Dann musst du das, das ist
eine Antwort, die du kriegst, dann musst du dir das mit
JQ noch ein bisschen Extracten
und dann baust du dir da
einzelne Zeilen zusammen und die
pipst du nach FZF.
Dann durchsuchst du die ganzen Sachen
in FZF und das,
was dann da rauskommt,
nachdem du es gefiltert hast in FZF,
splittest du wieder auf
und hängst ein SSH davor.
Natürlich ist ein bisschen mehr Shell Magic
dabei und im Endeffekt
kann ich jetzt bei mir einfach sagen,
äh, also das Skript, ich hab's jetzt hier nicht
drauf, ja, da sag ich Connection,
da sag ich COM, dann geht ein FZF,
dann geht bei mir so eine
quasi Searchliste auf
mit allen unseren
Linux-Servern, da kann ich
danach dann suchen, hier nach Qt Server
und wenn ich jetzt hier Enter drücke,
connectet er sich per SSH drauf.
Ich hab's sogar so erweitert, dass ich Multiselect
FZF benutzen kann.
Multiselect FZF.
Und wenn ich verschiedene,
ich kann jetzt mehrere Server
auswählen, zack,
und dann geht bei mir lokal ein TMAX auf
mit einem vierfach gesplitteten Panel
und lockt sich parallel auf vier
Servern ein. Richtige Hackermans-Shitter.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns
das Video fertig an.
Was? Das ging mir jetzt zu schnell.
Ey, das ist mir
viel zu fuddelig
und kleinteilig.
Da könnte ich mich nie dran orientieren.
Bei mir sieht das
anders aus. Aber wie gesagt,
es ist super individuell,
so Shell-Setup. Bei mir sieht das
anders aus. Wenn ich jetzt mal
in irgendein Repo reingehe,
sagen wir mal, ich gehe jetzt hier so
Advent of Code
gehe ich jetzt rein.
Hier in Status, da sieht man, hier ist was
un-committed drin. Ich sage jetzt git,
was habe ich denn da un-committed?
So, git commit
minus a, minus m, lel
Oh, und euch fällt schon auf, jetzt ist kein Ausrufezeichen
mehr hier. Also bei mir sehe ich
das hier im Prompt, was auch nice
ist, weil ich ja ein zwei-zeiliges Prompt habe, da kann
einiges angezeigt werden. Also wenn ich jetzt
hier sage touch1, dann seht ihr,
sehe ich gleich, okay, ich habe hier unbekannte
Files.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwas editiere an einem
Achso, da ist nichts drin.
Gut, dann machen wir git add
Jetzt zeigt er mir an, guck mal, ich habe hier was un-committedes
drin, was neues
un-committedes, blub.
So, jetzt ist es weg. Und wenn ich jetzt, sagen wir
hier echo 1, dann
sagt er mir, okay, jetzt hat sich was geändert. Also ich
sehe quasi an meiner Zeile hier oben,
ob ich irgendwelche un-committed Sachen drin habe.
Letztendlich, ich gucke da eigentlich nie so
wirklich drauf. Ich gucke immer nur,
steht hier hinter dem Brandstock irgendein Zeichen
und dann mache ich git status und gucke mir hinten
an, was Sache ist.
Und dann schaue ich damit die Pflege der ssh-config
oder wie, naja, ich halt. Du meinst, dass
man seine ganzen Hosts in die ssh-config
reinschreibt? Das habe ich eh nie gemacht,
die ganzen Hosts in die ssh-config reingeschrieben.
Ich habe schon immer
eine Mischung gemacht aus
ich weiß die Sachen aus dem Kopf
und
history durchsuchen.
Mittlerweile brauche ich das nicht mehr,
weil ich halt mein ansible connect
ssh connect Skript habe, was
ich aus dem ansible, den Kram holt.
Ja.
Also ssh-config mit allen Hosts drin
ist eh Pflege
Nightmare.
Ne, mache ich nicht.
Ich bin reiner git
Kommandozeilen-Enjoyer.
Ich bin sogar so verrückt, ich mache sogar
git merge-konflikt lösen
auf der Kommandozeile.
Mit vim. Nicht mit
vim diff, mit vim.
Also quasi
hier löschen und einfügen.
Aber ich gebe zu,
merge-konflikte sind einer der wenigen Fälle,
wo ich auch auf ein GUI zurückgreifen würde,
wenn es gar so umfangreich und groß wird.
Aber ansonsten
git kommandozeile
only.
...
dort hunderte Zeilen
geändert haben. Das hatte ich noch nicht.
Was ich hatte ist,
ich war beim letzten Laden, wo ich war,
ich hab mit,
ich hab's mir ausgedacht,
zu Zeiten, wo es das Wort
DevOps noch nicht gab,
quasi hauptverantwortlich für unsere
Infrastruktur Git-Repo,
da hat sich schon öfters was
geändert. Da hat sich schon mehrfach am Tag
mehrere Sachen dran geändert.
Aber das Schöne daran
ist halt gewesen, dass die Leute
oftmals halt für unterschiedliche Teile
zuständig waren. Wenn jetzt einer was
an irgendwelchen Konfigurationen,
sagen wir, für HA-Proxy geändert hat,
dann hat das seltenst
mit denen, die was geändert haben
für, keine Ahnung,
die irgendeinen Cron-Shop-Eintrag gemacht haben
oder so, konfliktet.
Es gab öfters mal Konflikte,
ja, beispielsweise, wenn dann
irgendwelche Basis-Konfigurationen und sowas geändert wurden,
aber die waren in der Regel
übersichtlich, oder mal halbwegs
übersichtlich. Da hat's
dann einmal fünf Dateien,
die vielleicht
jeweils drei Zeilen hatten,
die konfliktet sind, oder drei Abschnitte
hatten, die konfliktet sind.
Es ist nicht so, dass ich dort auf
der Shell tausendzeilige
Merge-Konflikte über hundert Dateien
lösen musste. Wobei ich da der Meinung
bin, wenn das öfters vorkommt,
ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen was an der
Organisation von, wie das gemacht
wird, verkackt.
Es kann natürlich immer mal passieren,
zwei Leute parallel sich einen Branch aufmachen,
dann zwei, drei Wochen dran arbeiten,
auch an ähnlichen Sachen
am Ende. Gibt's immer mal,
aber wenn das wirklich regelmäßig und öfters
auffällt, dann müsste man sich vielleicht
echt irgendwie mal überlegen,
ob man das nicht anders
organisieren kann. Das ist natürlich dann sehr
projektspezifisch, aber wenn
das wirklich täglich
oder wöchentlich öfters
vorkommt, dann klingt mir das
nicht nach der passenden
Branch und
Repo-Struktur,
dass man da immer
mehrfach in der Woche tausendzeilige
Merge-Konflikte hat. Wie ich sowas
mache, geht lock.
Ich mach sowas hier.
Äh.
Achso. So.
Mach ich sowas. Wenn ich mir denn
wirklich mal angucken muss.
Also ich mag das ja, es ist immer
die Frage, ob das in dem jeweiligen Projekt geht.
Also was ich mag, ist
von der GIT, von der Repo-Strukturierung,
was ich ganz gerne hab, ist,
Master oder Main, kann ja jeder
nennen, wie er will. Gibt's ja schon wieder
Leute, die instant getriggert sind, nur weil das
der Master-Branch ist.
Da gab's ja vor ein paar Jahren große
große Diskussion.
Also der Haupt-Branch,
ja. Ich nenn ihn mal Master
jetzt.
Ich find das ganz gut, wenn das so den
aktuellen,
wir nennen es mal,
wir denken, es funktioniert,
Entwicklungsstand ist.
Also das,
wo irgendwelche Features reingemerged
werden, die
aus
der Sicht des Entwicklers
soweit
okay sind, die jetzt aber nicht
umfangreich getestet sind. Also Master
ist so quasi der gemeinsame
Entwicklungsstand. So, dazu könnte man
das eigentlich sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob es da
irgendeinen coolen
DevOps-Ausdruck für gibt,
aber ich glaub, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Äh, so.
Und
wenn man
dort öfters mal
seine Feature-Branches drauf
rebased,
dann merkt man relativ schnell, wenn
andere Leute an was rumbauen, wo man
selbst gerade am rumbauen ist.
Wenn natürlich jetzt die Leute Feature-Branches
auschecken und jeder arbeitet
zwei, drei Monate oder so da dran,
dann ist kein Wunder, dass es dann immer
tausende Zeilen gibt, die es konfliktet.
Wenn man öfters mal seinen aktuellen
Master-Branch fetcht
und
oder
und drauf rebased,
dann fällt das relativ früh auf.
Zumindest war das bei uns immer so.
Ganz vermeiden lässt sich nicht.
Ja, aber ich hab das jahrelang gemacht.
Also mir Kram von anderen
Leuten angeguckt,
reviewed, gemerged, die Leute
zusammengesucht, die, wenn es mal einen Konflikt
gab, wissen, was denn jetzt der Stand ist,
wie es aussehen muss. Und
ich will nicht sagen, dass ich nie
ein extra Tool verwendet habe,
außer Kommandozeile und Vim,
aber zu 99% habe ich nur
Kommandozeile und Vim verwendet.
Und das ging ziemlich gut.
Es gibt 30 Milliarden
verschiedene Strategien, wie du deine Sachen
aufbauen kannst. Ich bin der Meinung,
man muss was finden, was passt.
Also ich kann euch sagen, wie wir das
für unsere Infrastruktur,
also für unser
Infrastructure as Code
Repo gemacht haben. Das kann ich euch
erzählen. Und zwar, wir hatten
einen Master-Branch,
der hieß auch tatsächlich noch Master,
weil der kommt aus Zeiten, da war es noch nicht
verpönt oder da musste man das noch nicht,
oder Default Main nennen.
Wir hatten einen Master-Branch,
dann hatten wir
einen Def-Branch,
einen Int-Branch, einen
Abnahme-Branch und einen
Prot-Branch.
Das lag daran,
weil
die Infrastruktur ja nicht unbedingt
losgelöst ist von allem anderen.
Das ist jetzt für ein Software-Projekt vielleicht
nicht unbedingt sinnvoll.
Bei einem Software-Projekt könnte man jetzt sagen,
okay, wir nehmen jetzt den aktuellen Stand
vom Master, wir denken, wir sind fertig,
wir taggen das jetzt und dann nehmen wir den Tag
und schieben das da rüber und dann ist gut
und dann gibt es vielleicht noch so.
Bei Infrastruktur ist das manchmal so,
dass das, dass
die Infrastruktur passen muss
zu dem,
was da gerade drinnen läuft.
Ja, zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel,
stellt euch vor, ihr habt einen Load-Balancer
und der Load-Balancer,
der braucht, der will
muss in den dritten Server
anbalancen,
oder ne, das ist ein doofes Beispiel.
Ihr bekommt eine neue, jetzt doch,
die Anwendung hat einen neuen
Pfad oder so hier,
oder sowas in der Richtung
und ihr braucht in den Load-Balancer-Regel,
dass dieses
richtig gebalanced wird.
Das macht natürlich dann schon Sinn,
wenn die Anwendungsversion
und die Infrastruktur
ähm,
die Installation zusammenpassen.
Weil, ne, also,
warum sollte ich
APV3 auf was balancen, was noch gar nicht da ist?
Oder noch schlimmer,
ich balance dann irgendwas nicht mehr,
was vielleicht in der alten Anwendungsversion
auch gebraucht wird.
Also da musste man schon gucken,
dass das ungefähr hinkommt.
Also es gibt manchmal Abhängigkeiten
von Infrastruktur zu der Software,
die drauf läuft und umgedreht.
Da kann man, kommt man manchmal nicht drum herum.
Deswegen gab es tatsächlich
für jede einzelne Anwendungsstage
einen eigenen Branch.
Und einmal im Monat
war das damals so.
Mittlerweile ist das schneller geworden.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie es jetzt machen,
weil ich bin jetzt schon seit über einem Jahr nicht mehr da,
also keine Ahnung,
wie das jetzt gehandhabt wird.
Ich hab gehört, die haben ein bisschen was umgestellt.
Muss ja immer gucken, dass das
up to date bleibt und zu den Anforderungen
drum herum passt.
Und einmal im Monat
habe ich geguckt, dass alles, was bis dahin
geöffnet wurde an Merchrequests,
dass das Ganze gemerged ist.
Im Zweifelsfall, wenn es tatsächlich mal Konflikte gab
oder wenn es Probleme gab oder ich beim Durchgucken
festgestellt habe,
da ist Mist drin.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viele
Verschreiber ich bei irgendwelchen
Hostnamen gesehen habe oder
dass Leute nicht Pfeil geschrieben haben,
sondern keine Ahnung,
Liffe oder irgendwie sowas.
Alles mögliche. Dann wurde das
Ganze gefixt, wurde reingepusht
noch einmal und einmal
im Monat zu einem Stichtag
haben wir gesagt, okay, alles, was bis dahin
jetzt offen ist, alles, was bis dahin fertig ist,
nehmen wir jetzt
und packen das. Einmal habe ich
einen neuen Tag draufgesetzt und dann packen wir
das einmal nach Dev, rollen dort
komplett einmal neu die Infrastruktur aus.
Wir haben das quasi komplett weggeschmissen.
Das ist ja auch der große Vorteil von
Infrastructure as Code.
Okay, wir haben nicht alles weggeschmissen.
Irgendwelche ESX-Server neu installiert
oder so. Also zumindest die logische
Infrastruktur da oben drauf.
Weggeschmissen, soweit möglich
neu erstellt,
deployed, geguckt, hat alles funktioniert.
Dann
gab es noch irgendwelche Tests, die danach
durchgeführt wurden. Ist gut.
Wenn das funktioniert hat, war gut.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert hat, musste noch was gefixt werden.
Da gab es dann beispielsweise irgendeine
Version 1.0.1
oder sowas, gab es einen neuen Tag.
Der fix,
wurde auf dem
Dev-Branche getestet.
Wenn das funktioniert hat, wurde es cherrypicked dann hier rein.
Und spätestens ab hier hast du
eigentlich so gut wie keine Fehler mehr gehabt.
Und dann nachts wurde das automatisch
ausgerollt. Die Infrastruktur changes.
Und ob man das jetzt Git
Flow oder wie auch immer nennt, es muss passen.
Das gibt es
ja an sich gar nicht. Es gibt mal irgendeinen Typ, der
einen Artikel geschrieben hat, der so hieß.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es sogar ein
Kommandozeilentool dafür. Aber ich finde, das macht keinen Sinn.
Das muss einfach passen zum jeweiligen
Projekt, zur Infrastruktur, zum Softwareprojekt,
was auch immer man in seinem Git-Repo handhabt.
Und wie die Regelungen
drumherum sind.
Das schöne an Git ist, du kannst nahezu alles
da drin abbilden.
Übrigens so ein bisschen, ein bisschen
in die Richtung macht es der Kernel auch.
Glaube ich zumindest. Ich weiß nicht, wie es aktuell ist.
Für den Linux Kernel
gibt es auch
mehrere Branches, wo man Sachen drauf fixen kann.
Es gibt Stable Branch,
glaube ich den Old Stable Branch und sowas.
Bisschen wie bei
Pandemian.
Und dann?
Das ist ja eigentlich eines der
hauptsächlichen Anwendungszwecke für Git.
Das Verwalten von
Source Code.
Was ist
daran schlecht, bzw. was sollten
sie anders machen?
Letztendlich ist GitHub
eine Source Code Ablage, wenn man es mal auf
Deutsch sagen will.
Plus halt noch ein paar nette Features drumherum.
Ihr müsst das Video jetzt mal
fertig gucken, sonst wird das ja echt nix.
Zwei Stunden am Labern, wir haben drei Videos
geguckt oder so.
Ja, das ist gut.
Das kann ich echt empfehlen.
Es ist das
Hakee Leak.
Was? Push on Save?
Das habe ich auch noch nicht gehört,
dass es Leute gibt, die Push on Save machen.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Wenn ich in den Source Code reinschreibe,
keckle, größer keck W
und aus Versehen Ctrl S drücke,
dann pusht das automatisch, oder was?
Ja, das ist natürlich nicht so
sinnig irgendwo.
Vor allem blickt ja dann gar keiner
mehr durch.
Vor allem, wenn du, stell dir mal vor,
alle im gleichen Branch und alle pushen
beim Save. Ja, da ist ja das, okay,
da sind Probleme ja auf jeden Fall vorprogrammiert.
Wenn das alle in ihrem eigenen Branch machen,
ist es noch okay. Dann kann man es danach wenigstens
resetten und ordentliche
Command Messages machen.
Push minus Force on Save.
Scheiß drauf, was die anderen
gepusht haben. Ja, okay, ey, das gibt halt
übelst Chaos. Ja, das wundert mich da nicht.
Und irgendwann
machen alle minus F, weil kein Push
mehr ohne minus F funktioniert.
Jeder komplett unterschiedliche
History-Lokal.
Ich kann es so oft genug sagen,
mir ist sein Shell-Setup
viel zu kleinteilig und fuddelig,
wenn ich die tausend Pop-Ups und Sachen sehe.
Ich kann es so oft genug sagen,
mir ist sein Shell-Setup
viel zu kleinteilig und fuddelig,
wenn ich die tausend Pop-Ups und Sachen sehe.
This is all FZF
and it goes way just beyond a fuzzy
peaker. I got a video covering
everything with the features and options
you wanna set up. It's up here.
When it comes to the Terminal,
there's nothing like a good TUI.
These are the Terminal User Interfaces.
Ich mag das nicht.
We've seen Yazy earlier
and here's LazyGit,
one of the tools I use for Git.
Alter, wie viele von diesen Tools
gibt's eigentlich?
Und warum?
Leute, Git Command Line.
Git Command Line ist das
einzig wahre.
Das hier ist
im Prinzip wahrscheinlich genauso Schrott
wie, also Schrott, Schrott ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht, man kann damit bestimmt arbeiten,
aber das hier ist wahrscheinlich
genauso Schrott wie die ganzen
Git-Integrationen in irgendwelchen IDE's.
Was ich da schon für ein Shit
gesehen hab an Comets, gerade IntelliJ
ist da so der Haupt-Offender
bei diesen Sachen.
Leute, was
diese
IntelliJ-Git-Integration
da teilweise
für Dinger schon gebastelt hat,
leere Comets, drei Stück
nacheinander, wo man sich fragt, wie jetzt?
Warum? Warum ist das da?
Ja, das wussten die Leute dann auch nicht,
weil das hat halt die IDE gemacht.
Deswegen finde ich, Git Command
Line ist das einzig wahre.
Da weißt du, was es macht,
weil du hast selbst eingetippt
und es ist, wenn man sich ein bisschen
damit beschäftigt hat, meiner Meinung nach
einfacher
und logischer als
die x-te IDE
GUI-Integration für Git.
Und das finde ich genauso unsinnig.
Disclaimer, ich hab's noch nie
verwendet.
Alles das kann ich ohne Probleme
mit der Commando-Zeile machen.
Vielleicht hat das coole Features,
aber einen Container stoppen, starten
geht auch easy über die Command Line.
Da brauche ich das GUI nicht für.
LazyGit und LazyDocker
in this Video up here, around
NeoVim-Git-Integration.
Ein Vorteil, den muss ich jetzt nochmal sagen,
ein Vorteil, das nicht über irgendwelche
Zwischentools zu machen ist,
dass man einfach lernt, was passiert.
Dass man versteht, was unter der Haube
da eigentlich abgeht.
Wenn du jetzt in IntelliJ rumklickst,
bis du dann irgendwie einen Comet hast
da drüber, dann weißt du zwar,
okay, ich hab jetzt meine Dateien hinzugefügt,
aber du verstehst nicht wirklich,
was unter der Haube passiert.
Du hast zum Beispiel keine Ahnung,
wenn du sagst Pull, dass ein Pull
quasi eigentlich ein Skript in dem Sinn ist,
was mehrere Sachen macht.
Portena ist auch so ein Ding,
was ich nicht mag.
Tom, es muss so sein, dass es für euren
Workflow gut funktioniert.
Es ist für euch vollkommen egal,
ob ich das mag oder nicht.
Aber gibt natürlich kein Gifts ab jetzt.
Wat? Jetzt, das jetzt hat er mich abgehängt.
Jetzt blick ich nicht mehr durch. Was zum?
Moment, nochmal, nochmal, nochmal. NeoVim.
Okay.
Ich bin da wieder komplett von weg.
Ich war früher auch Hardcore-Vim-Fanatiker
auf der Comet-Line. Ich hatte das Ding,
das war noch pre-NeoVim-Zeiten.
Ich hatte das Ding übelst customised
mit Plugin-Managern und
58 verschiedene Plugins
und Gedöns. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich
gesagt hab, unsicher wie der
Plugin-Manager damals hieß,
Vim-Plug oder so,
ähm,
jedes Mal, wenn ich das geupdatet hab,
ging irgendwas wieder nicht.
Ich hab das ultra customised.
Bis ich dann irgendwann draufgekommen bin,
ja, ist ja schön und gut, wenn ich mein Vim-Lokal
customised habe, also,
ich hab das auch, ich hab da super viel Wert
drauf gelegt, dass ich alles schön logisch
gemappt habe mit Leader-Space
und, und, und was auch immer.
Bis ich dann irgendwann mal draufgekommen bin,
es ist richtig kacke, sobald ich mich remote
auf den Server verbinde,
hab ich die ganze Custom-Config nicht mehr
und ich muss im Kopf umdenken,
wie ging das Ganze
jetzt nochmal in Vanilla-Vim.
Und deswegen bin ich da
wieder von weg, weil ich einfach
einen Großteil meines Tages remote per SSH
auf irgendwelchen Servern verbringe
und dort was machen muss und ich keinen Bock hab
im Kopf, umzuschalten zwischen
meinem lokalen Vim und meinem Remote-Vim.
Deswegen bin ich da komplett
von weg und meine Vim-Config hat jetzt keine Ahnung,
60 Zeilen oder so und nix, keine
Plugins mehr. Wenn man sein Vim
aufmodzen will
zu nem, zu ner Javascript-IDE
ja, oder irgendeiner
Go-IDE oder so, ja dann kommste da nicht drumherum.
Dann muss man das aber im Kopf
auch irgendwie
als, als andere Software
sehen, so ein bisschen wie Visual Studio Code,
sodass
man nicht denkt, oh ich geh jetzt in
mein Vim, sondern ich geh in mein
ja, modded Vim.
Und das klar im Kopf
ist, okay, wenn ich Vim aufmache,
dann krieg ich den Raw-Vim,
so wie ich in Remote auch habe
und wenn ich mein modded Special-Vim
aufmache, ist das halt was anderes.
MDM suckt ultra,
so Mobile-Device-Kram ist einfach
erstens
alles, was ich davon mitbekommen hab.
Bisher. Weiter.
...
Siehste, das ist cool, ich gette
komplett, dass das nice ist.
Du hast das aber auf dem Remote-System
nicht. Wenn du dich dran gewöhnst,
ah, okay, ich möchte jetzt ne Datei
öffnen, also drücke ich Control
X und Dings und Dings, dann tippst
du auf einmal was, weil du schon so im Kopf
drin hast, ah fuck, das gibt's ja aufm Server gar nicht.
Ich hab dann zwischenzeitlich sogar angefangen
meine...
...
Ich hatte dann irgendwie auf jedem Server auf einmal
so nen, keine Ahnung, 150 MB
Home Directory,
wo ich mich nur eingeloggt hab, weil ich einige Sachen
voll mitgenommen hab, das war halt auch kacke.
Deswegen, ohne Scheiß, wenn ihr viel Remote
auf Servern unterwegs seid,
sind die Default-Linux-Tools
nach wie vor
das Beste, was man benutzen kann.
...
Das finde ich, man glaubt es gar nicht, aber das ist tatsächlich ganz cool.
Wenn man sich auf eine Sache konzentrieren muss, du kannst alles andere abdunkeln, hat was.
Aber das ist mir, da ploppt, laufen irgendwas auf und Dings, das würde mich so ablenken.
So weit sind wir schon, Leute.
Vim Package Manager mit Package Registry und Suche.
Eigentlich cool, aber eigentlich auch schon beängstigt.
Und ich finde, dass es krass overrides, aber wenn er damit klarkommt, ist ja klar, ist okay.
Da gebe ich ihm recht.
But if you feel like you don't, just chill.
Lastly, as you've seen, I take everything to the terminal, including my writing, which I do a lot of.
For journaling, newsletters, blogs.
Es muss für euch im Endeffekt einfach passen.
Ich habe die letzten Jahre über natürlich auch ein bisschen was in meiner Shell-Config gemacht, aber kaum.
Ja, das tut einfach.
Ich komme damit einfach gut klar, so wie es jetzt ist.
Ich müsste auch mal wieder pushen, weil das auf GitHub ist nicht mehr ganz aktuell.
Ja, aber ich komme damit einfach gut klar.
Der hält da Steine am Start hier.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Ich habe Mist gebaut.
Das sieht nach einer Wasserkühlung aus.
Oder so einem Aufsatz.
Der Auer.
Homelapse-Server.
Oh, nee, nee, genug Homelapse jetzt.
Was ist das?
Infinite Lego Candy Factory.
Excellent.
Bisschen sinnlos, Lego-Bau-Videos.
Der Versand-Track, so.
Der wurde schon seit Jahren nicht mehr geupdatet.
Ich verliere ihn.
Ich verliere immer sehr schnell die Lust an irgendwelchen Projekten.
Dumm nur, wenn ich den Kram selbst verwende.
Ja, also beispielsweise mein Emote-Dashboard hier verwende ich selbst.
Und das müsste dringend mal modernisiert werden.
Genauso wie der Fiat Champ als auch der VM-Champ.
Also, die müssten...
Ich hätte für beides...
Also für den Fiat Champ hätte ich sehr viele Sachen.
Und für den VM-Champ hätte ich auch ein paar Sachen.
Aber oftmals habe ich da einfach keinen Bock.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Ja.
Und...
War nicht sehr logisch.
Ja.
Wenn ich gesagt habe, ich mache das nicht, weil ich mich remote einloggen muss.
Wenn ihr euch nie remote einloggt, dann ist das für euch anders.
Ja.
Das ist das essentiellste, was du machen musst.
Um richtige Hackerman zu werden.
Du musst Einsen in deiner Browserzeile schreiben.
Und nicht nur Einsen, sondern du musst überall Einsen reinschreiben und copypasten.
Das ist ganz, ganz wichtig.
Was für ein Emote.
dashboard das hier das hier das ist das was ich auf dem zweiten rechner an habe um hier den den
kram anzuzeigen den man hier ab und zu als overlay sieht oder sowas hier abzuspielen
da habe ich selbst gebaut vor jahren und es sind die gleichen bugs drin die vor jahren
auch schon drin waren zum beispiel dass die suche brauchen erst ab und zu was eisig jubel
abgeschaltet bock ja das gehört ja mittlerweile zu einer russischen icq wird abgeschaltet ich
weiß meine icq nummer heute noch okay ich gebe zu zum größten teil werde ich ein bisschen drüber
nachdenken fällt die mir noch ein welchen trend die verpasst haben die frage ist das
deine
weißt du die noch da müsste ich mir gedanken drüber machen was meine icq nummer war es die
für was die verpasst haben die waren mit abstand der größte und bekannteste im zweifelsfall
wahrscheinlich ja irgendein trend verpasst was irgendwas im zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich
ja doch das was bei allen so ist es gibt was neues was einfacher ist und die leute
mehr angesprochen
der über Miss Los M любов oder altes
ee
46 juni Jakarta google accept meals no time behaviors was wisst ihr was cinematosing computations auf welcher schicht war so der umbruch war mit icq? belki die voice chat geschichte? nee icq war schon vor smartphone kaum noch groß angesagt oder . selbst zu skype zeiten zu 2007 настолько noch gar nicht so verbreitet aber icu hat man schon mal benutzt weiß ich gar nicht
26 juni wird eingeschaltet eigentlich abgeschaltet eingeschaltet mail.ru
wusstet ihr dass mail.ru eine anti-cheat software anbietet mail.ru anti-cheat
die kökonuts ja mail. mail.ru anti-cheat auch so ein ding
ende einer ära ja vielleicht steht ja in dem artikel was was sie verkackt
haben mirabilis ja oder mirabilis genau das so hieß der ganze
damals gab es auch den aol messenger und solche geschichten kennt ihr noch diese
diese ollen icq games sumo volleyball das da gab es so eine mini game sammlung
auf icq und so weiter
das da habe ich stunden und tage gespielt mit leuten damals bei icq es
gibt noch es gibt eine esl liga für sumo volleyball das ist aber das nur ein
profil gewesen ja das blobvolleyball das das kenn ich aber sumo volleyball war
das bei icq vk messenger ja genau das ist natürlich auch das was man unbedingt
verwenden möchte dann ja das ist natürlich guck mal hier
bisschen sätke aber letztendlich ist ja nur noch der namen davon übrig ja icq ist
echt schon so ein relikt ein relikt aus der vergangenheit die meisten leute
heutzutage kennen das ja gar nicht mehr großartig also die die die sumer ich
glaube die hatten nie was mit icq groß zu tun
ja ich weiß dass sie das ausgetauscht haben ja ok ein bisschen sinnlos lego
bau wieder oh das wird es aber advanced guck mal hier der hat da sogar irgendeine arduino karte
kamera oder sowas drüber installier mal z im hinter ist eine gute idee
moment snapshots ich delete mal kurz den snapshot weil ansonsten wenn die
snapshot zu groß mit der zeit da mache ich einen neuen snapshot weil er weiß
das ding installiert wieder gott um die welt wahrscheinlich nach über ein
package manager und dann installiere ich mal weil ich
habe übelst hunger aber das liegt vielleicht auch daran weil ich gerade
lego candy factory gelesen
chance zack ok z editor was hast du welches davon hast du installiert dass
da eins oder die die shit variante jetzt heute nachmittag noch mal streamen
weiß ich nicht noch unklar also auf jeden fall nicht set servers weil das
wird bestimmt nicht gefixt sein bis heute mittag ja entferne war die warum
ging das jetzt so schnell da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder
ja entferne mal die äh warum ging das jetzt so schnell da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder warum ging das jetzt so schnell da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder
stimmt da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder warum ging das jetzt so schnell da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder
stimmt da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht oder wir machen man clean bild oder clean bild
wir machen man clean bild oder clean bild
wir machen man clean bild oder clean bild ach nee das war nur die dependencies
ach nee das war nur die dependencies
ach nee das war nur die dependencies dafür ach so gibt's für z schon bleibt weil
dafür ach so gibt's für z schon bleibt weil
dafür ach so gibt's für z schon bleibt weil sie nicht gibt's okay jetzt wird erst
sie nicht gibt's okay jetzt wird erst
sie nicht gibt's okay jetzt wird erst mal eine halbe stunde kompiliert blazingly
mal eine halbe stunde kompiliert blazingly
mal eine halbe stunde kompiliert blazingly fast rast es gibt ein punkt da ist rast
fast rast es gibt ein punkt da ist rast
alles andere als Blazingly fast und das sind die Buildtimes. Rust Buildtimes sind Blazingly slow.
Aber eins muss man Rust lassen, der lastet immer richtig schön den Rechner aus beim
Kompilieren. Pass mal auf, gleich geht es richtig zur Sache, sobald es die Git-Repos ausgecheckt
hat. Vor allem, was lädt sich da jetzt eigentlich alles runter? Warum dauert das so lange? Okay,
da gucken wir jetzt nicht zu. Ich will mir jetzt die Lego Candy Factory angucken. Das ist aber
schon enorm advanced Lego Kram. Ja, es hat ein bisschen was von der Raspberry Pi Cam. Leute,
wisst ihr, ist das offizielles Lego Zeug oder ist das Zusatz Lego Zeug? EV3 ist offiziell. Okay,
richtig nice. Okay. High IQ Detection. Mal kurz gucken, ob da jetzt. Was muss ich machen? Rust up?
Ne,
wie geht das? Die update? Ich muss erstmal meinen Rust updaten,
damit ich den Editor runter laden kann, um den Editor zu kompilieren dann. Alles klar.
Richtige High Performer mindset der hier gebraucht wird. So, jetzt. Guckt euch das
mal an. Rust braucht einfach komplett acht CPU cores. Aber wenigstens, das ist jetzt,
wenn du CPU-Kursen hast oder wenn du CPU-Kursen hast, dann brauchst du, wenn du C++-Cursen hast,
aber wenigstens, das ist jetzt, wenn du CPU-Kursen hast, wenn du C++-Cursen hast,
wenn du C++-Cursen hast, dann brauchst du dann einfach nochmal 55 verdichten,
Plus Plus Projekt, sonst was. Er kombiniert
nicht viel anders, solange der viel parallel machen
kann. Aber die Build Time von
Rust, die sind schon immer sehr Resident
Sleeper. Ja, das lassen wir ihm mal
bilden im Hintergrund. Ist halt
cool gemacht, oder? Nice,
gecuttet. Das wäre das
finale Produkt, wenn ich das gebaut hätte.
So ungefähr.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich,
ich kenn mich. Wenn ich mit sowas anfange,
dann würde ich
garantiert nicht
mich damit zufrieden geben, sondern
ich kenn mich.
Wenn ich mich in sowas reinsteigere,
ich hätte dann
angefangen, irgendwann mit Custom
ESP32 Firmware mein
Lego-Ding zu steuern.
Über Zigbee am besten noch.
Einfach, weil es geht.
Ich kenn mich. Ich
steigere mich in sowas dann immer
ziemlich weit rein.
Und übertreib's dann auch mit dem
Zeitaufwand, der da reingesteckt
wird.
Irgendwie ist ein bisschen...
Was passiert da? Der sucht jetzt
Gelbe raus, oder wie?
Das Blöde an diesem Candy ist,
ich finde diese Dinger schmecken halt richtig kacke.
Bei mir wäre da anderes Candy
drinne. Dann würde halt die Maschine
nicht mehr funktionieren.
Ah, das war ein Bug, verstehe.
Das ist aber nicht offizielles Lego, oder?
Das ist ja schon,
wenn ich mir das so angefasse, fast ein halbes Breadboard.
Mini, Mini.
Das ist in, ähm...
zum Ansteuern von einem
Motor, oder?
Lego spricht I2C.
Sehr nice.
Manchmal bleibt es stecken.
Das ist nicht so praktisch.
Der hat aber auch viele Lego-Teile auf Vorrat.
Sekunde, was macht meine
Editor-Installation?
Ah, braucht immer noch 100% CPU-Last.
Ursacht ein bisschen Load.
Jetzt, jetzt hängt's erst mal eine Weile.
Ja, Rust-Pepega-Buildtimes.
Oh no.
Was man daran
auch schön sieht ist,
etwas hinzubekommen, was zu 80%
funktioniert.
Ist gar nicht so schwierig.
Dass es, sagen wir mal so,
nahezu immer funktioniert,
das wird schwieriger.
Was du kombinierst, Z.
Z-Editor.
Der jetzt unter Linux laufen soll, angeblich.
Auf welcher Basis läuft
das Lego-Zeug?
Also Controller-technisch?
Ist da auch schon irgendwelche Mods für?
Ja, hab ich. Aber angeblich
geht das jetzt. Ordentlicher
als meine Breadboard zu aussehen.
Zwar kein Breadboard,
aber vergleichbar.
Richtig nice.
Und es hat, eins muss man sagen,
es hat einen sehr satisfyingen Sound.
Oh, wir sind beim letzten Package,
was kompiliert wird.
Aber immer noch 100% CPU-Last.
Auf 8-Kern.
Das muss man Rust ja lassen,
auch wenn der Build-Prozess lahm ist.
Die CPU-Auslastung ist schön multithreaded.
Warte nicht.
Oh, muss ja die
Bande höher machen.
Ach ne, ok, Deckel drüber, geht auch.
Aber irgendwo staut sich's
da gerade.
Ah, das sieht nach
einem Arduino aus, oder?
Einen von den neuen,
von den neueren Sorten
Arduinos. Ich hab mal ne Ahnung,
welcher das ist. Nano, ja.
Und es gibt sogar noch ein paar LED-Strips.
Wisst ihr,
was ich grad so im Kopf hab? Was war das?
Nochmal. Es gab doch früher so
nen Channel, der immer
Bacon-Strips, Bacon-Strips, Bacon-Strips.
So, 2010.
Was war das nochmal?
Weiß das jemand noch? Bacon-Strips, Bacon-Strips.
Ihr denkt euch jetzt wahrscheinlich auch,
der Max dreht komplett durch, aber
wisst ihr, was ich meine?
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern?
Bacon-Strips, Bacon-Strips.
Ihr habt keine Ahnung mehr,
genauso wenig wie ich. Bacon-Strips.
Epic Mealtime.
Genau.
Bacon-Strips, Bacon-Strips.
Vor 12 Jahren.
Genau.
Das meinte ich, ja.
Wie kommst du darauf? Weil ich grad gesagt hab,
LED-Strip.
Irgendwie hatte ich im Kopf Bacon-Strip
danach.
Der Hunger ist zu groß. Ja, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Was gibt denn das
jetzt? Ah,
Beleuchtung. Verstehe.
Ah,
sehr cool.
Der zeigt an, wie viel noch drin ist, oder?
Das ist, ohne Mist, das ist auch so ein Projekt.
Damit kannst du Stunden und
Tage zubringen
und Spaß dran haben.
Sinnvoll ist es nicht.
Kommt nix am Ende raus, wo du sagen kannst,
oh, jetzt hab ich was gebaut, was jetzt
voll viel bringt oder so. Aber du hast was gelernt.
Und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass man,
ist ja manchmal auch so nicht direkt zu erkennen,
dass Skills, die man mit sowas
erlernt, sich irgendwann mal auszahlen.
Also, komplett anderem
Zusammenhang.
Ich bastel ja auch ganz gerne
Microcontroller-Kram und sowas, ja.
Und ich hatte bis jetzt noch nix,
wo ich gesagt hätte, oh ja,
gute Arbeit, ich
bau mal irgendwie nen Microcontroller
irgendwo ein und bau ne custom Firmware und so.
Aber zumindest haben sich so die
ein oder anderen Sachen ausgezahlt.
Sei es, dass man sich
ein bisschen mit C++,
wenn man auch kotzen musste dabei,
aber ein bisschen mit C++ beschäftigt hat.
Es ist nie verkehrt,
sowas zu machen. Erstens, es macht Spaß.
Und zweitens, auf irgendeine Art und Weise
kann man die Skills gebrauchen.
Es gibt doch schon einen Band-Compiler.
Oder meinst du für Lego?
Jetzt wird's aber echt extra
advanced.
Mit Förderband.
Das ist ja halbes Factorio hier am Start.
Was wird das jetzt?
So genau hab ich's auch noch nicht gecheckt.
Ein Candy-Sortierungsautomat
oder so.
Ach, ich hab's!
Genau!
Der randomizt die jetzt wieder.
Ja, der randomizt die jetzt wieder
und dann schüttet er sie wieder oben rein.
Das ist unendlich lang sortiert.
Das wird's sein, ja.
Nicht so ganz.
Ja, das randomizt.
Jetzt, jetzt übertreibt
das aber, hä?
Ja, deswegen Infinite. Ich hab's auch erst nicht gecheckt.
Sehr coole Sache.
Wobei, wenn ich mir das Ding angucke,
vermuten würde, das macht's trotzdem nicht lang.
Nach ein paar Umdrehungen ist Schluss.
Wahrscheinlich.
Warum genau braucht er das Ding jetzt?
Warum kann er die nicht einfach vom Fließband wieder oben reinkippen
mit Infinite?
Halbes Amazon-Lagerhaus, ja.
Die ist Destiny.
Ja, da fehlt das agile Scrum-Team dabei.
Ah, das ist, dass das Ding nicht so oft
fehlanschlägt mit Boxen davor.
Macht das dunkel.
Ist das der Grund, warum echte
so Beförderbände auch oftmals
solche
Dinge haben, dass irgendwelche Sensoren
da drin nicht durch Licht gestört werden?
Gebungslicht?
Staubschutz.
Ja.
Lookt das better?
Ich hab keinen Unterschied gesehen zu vorher.
Das ist schon Fivehead.
Das ist schon wirklich
richtig high-IQ-Shit.
Was war das Problem
mit dem White Candy?
Ah, die Kamera erkennt's nicht richtig.
Ah, das ist quasi, wenn
weiße Candy wird rausgefiltert.
Ja, stimmt.
Bei mir gibt's nichts mehr zum Sortieren.
Aber ich mag diese Sorte nicht.
Also wahrscheinlich nicht.
Moin.
Also das ist wirklich Next Level
Fivehead-Shit.
Endlich mal einer, der
weiß, wie's funktioniert.
Es bootet.
Das ist wirklich richtig
Next Level.
Wann kommt das nächste Dual mit dem Friseur?
Frag ihn mal. Frag mal. Frag mal.
Er drückt sich immer
davor.
Wann war denn das? Boah, keine Ahnung.
Vor fünf, sechs Jahren oder so.
Das ist schon super-Advanceder-Shit.
Der hat da bestimmt
mehr als 18 Minuten drin.
Der hat da bestimmt ein paar Tage dran gebaut.
Selbst wenn du die
übelsten Lego-Skills hast.
Da muss jetzt... Chat.
Ich hab noch einen Verbesserungsvorschlag.
Da muss noch eine Heizplatte
drunter und
die weißen Abfall-Candys
werden eingeschmolzen.
Das ist wirklich halbes Real-Life-Faktorio
hier. Und dann wieder von vorne.
Naja.
Das Ding ist halt, nachdem da keine neuen
in den Kreislauf reinkommen an weißen Candys,
sind die halt
irgendwann einfach mal aussortiert.
Und es passiert nichts. Es geht einfach wirklich
infinite weiter.
Der ist schon wirklich sehr nice.
Der hat da bestimmt viel Spaß dran gehabt, das zu bauen.
Oh, hier.
Dazwischendurch scheinen mir auch ein paar runtergefallen zu sein.
Richtig cool gemacht.
Ein äußerst
satisfying Video.
Ja, das ist wirklich echt halbes
Real-Life-Faktorio.
Vor allem, was es
sehr Faktorio macht, ist dieser
Conveyor Belt.
Oder auf
Deutsch
Förderungslauf
Band oder so.
Was ist denn das? Förderband?
Förderband.
Christus Brezel. Dankeschön.
Zapp und Marcel. Pog-Subscriptions.
Danke, Leute. Also, das war aber wirklich
krasses Zeug.
Also, da musst du dich auch wirklich
gut mit den einzelnen Sachen auskennen
und wissen, welche
Teile es gibt. Also, selbst
wenn du im Kopf hast, ah, so und so könnte man's
machen, du musst erst mal was daraus bauen
für die passenden Teile, die es gibt.
Richtig, richtig nice.
Ja, High-IQ.
Aber sowas von High-IQ.
Um nicht zu sagen,
PyFed. Okay.
Nochmal.
Er muss nicht nochmal kompilieren.
Ich hab einfach nicht rechtzeitig sudo mein Passwort
eingetippt.
Okay, lass uns mal gucken, ob der Editor jetzt funktioniert.
Also, Z
PostChamp, PostChamp,
PostChamp.
Fuck.
Ist immer noch kaputt.
Valken. Ja, das liegt halt.
Valken in meiner VM funktioniert halt
wahrscheinlich einfach nicht gut genug.
Aber Hauptsache, wir haben
eine Viertelstunde kompiliert. Okay.
Snapshots, revert.
Yes. In Rust gibt es keine
Fehler. Ja, direkt.
Erst mal Mozilla verklagen.
Ist das Mindeste, was wir machen können, oder?
Okay, wir haben rollbacked.
Und jetzt werden wir gleich
den Snapshot deleten.
Können ja nicht so viele sein.
Was da im Snapshot
drin ist. Und Chat,
wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mache? Ich werde
jetzt Nudeln mit Lachs
fruttern. Kann schon was sagen.
Fressen.
Übelst Hunger hab. Rebooten mal.
Nudeln mit Lachs-Time, Leute.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich hoffe, Zedke-Servers ist
bald gefixt, dass wir streamen
können. Ich hatte gestern
richtig Bock drauf, aber ich hatte keinen Bock, dass
diesen
Hin- und Herkopier-Sachen
verdecken und umschalten zu machen.
Oh, mein Autoresize ist
broken. Warum denn
das? Warum ist mein
Autodesplay-Resize kaputt? Egal.
Wir rebooten einfach nochmal.
Und jetzt im Fullscreen. Und dann ist gut.
Fixed.
Ja, nice. Problem behoben.
Einfach im Fullscreen starten.
Lul.
Ich hätte übrigens gar nicht rebooten müssen.
Ich hätte wahrscheinlich einfach nur X neu starten müssen und gut wär
gewesen. Alles klar.
Leute, ich geh was essen. Wir hören uns.
Bis denn. Macht's gut. See you.